all right we hola laughs welcome to the
i lords podcast episode number 99 one
away from 100 it's another glorious
Sunday we are back at the roundtable on
the Lord's Day I'm extremely excited
about our special guests and we've got
the latest intend to direct crackdown 3
launched aftermath Shawn Layden
interview and black desert finger to
discuss so we gonna get right into it
oh thank you sir Lord who is not only a
good friend to the rel but also from the
Lord finally got the chance the
opportunity to meet in the flesh and III
2018 this Lord's passion for gaming film
and anime truly resonates and is
arguably one of the most passionate
up-and-coming members of our entire
gaming community introducing the host of
the smash and otaku fix podcast as well
as a panelist for the saltiest gaming
and GOG podcast the mixer streaming and
anime king and the Lord who may or may
not have to been deleted after Avengers
and game is released from the Lone Star
State in making his debut into the realm
of the Lords mommy Lord bloody knuckles
how're you doing sir hey what's going on
kognito I love that intro that is a
great intro I don't care unlike another
certain person on the on the podcast
here is I will actually bend the knee if
it goes down to it but I already have
faith in my knowledge and what's gonna
happen so I don't think that's going to
be a thing I would have to bend the knee
if I was wrong or King what happens only
one true king okay just abandon me again
for what again I want the refresh the
yeah okay
what if Pietro also known as Quicksilver
was gonna be alive after the end of
endgame okay yeah yeah yeah I told you
that
they will be doing sometimes you talk
about some suppose a plot that you got
they gave to you and you got all
information and I said yeah you know
what
I totally recall it because I think this
is gonna be my best bet in the ever
because you will officially you won't do
it on camera you gonna do it real well
I'll let you go take this brand-new baby
that you're saving me off of it's gonna
be put to work where the other you gonna
be right over there with right in that
corner I like the cool long over dude
you've been in on the run before but
it's short capacities but it's good to
finally have you in the well and yeah I
know that's what's actually made this
one special is that this one we're
actually getting it where I'm on the
whole show cuz the fur people don't know
I've been on twice and the first time
was the destiny topic before destiny to
launched almost almost a year and a half
ago just before uh III last year I was
on for that segment for like 30 minutes
and then a couple weeks ago when hope
was on hopping in on the the Activision
Bungie split because I got heated on
that yeah that was out without it I'd do
it for those those topics you gotta have
a we're gonna bring it so it's always
good to get your takes minute so it's
good to have you let's get this thing
popping man let's do it all right and
you know we have the Four Horsemen of
gaming those original Lords of the realm
here at the round table
my co-host with the Comox my brother
from another mother the difficult game
Conqueror and the how of the young wolf
my man
Lord addict I doing sir doing pretty
good
[Music]
Adam - when I thought he was you know
had a fire I thought you had a red build
the red bull and I'm perfectly wide
awake but that's all you get
pretty much just cracked down I got a
start Metro probably tomorrow I got to
do the review for crackdown first no no
wait till we get into that topic is
gonna be very interesting dudes ain't
gonna like the King off for that right
all right and of course we have our most
technical gaming experience
[Music]
under the table that's coming with their
soul unlike everyone else there ain't no
so you know yeah you know what I'm happy
that you like it you know because a lot
of people out here upset with the
Boonton as going on and getting a lot of
socks to the but um but I'm glad that
you actually could play a whole
experience have you had a good
experience whether you played a whole
experience do you be able to log in and
in the game come back I want to hear
this - yeah no I've actually I've
actually had no issues going through I'm
actually on the fourth mission after you
save I think you know back the fourth
mission way yeah cuz after I did all the
work you spent half the day trying to
get in and that's why you on the court
I've only a half of my 10-hour trial I
was you picked up a stopper to you on
the tribe hey remember on xbox ten-hour
free trial a week early and I'm trying
to pace myself because I don't get that
normally it's like an hour and a half a
day I played that last night because I
was actually you know working
uh-huh let me just ask one question
mm-hmm play ten hours in a week of
destiny
nobody's different is it I see what he's
saying because what it is is the EA
access version on Xbox they've given you
ten hours but they let you play a week
early
whereas the EA access premier origin
thing on PC gives you the full game of a
week because if he relaxes
did he ask wait
and then turn it back in after e3 last
serie that game was already paid off
I ride away hey King yo tell me could
you just stop playing destiny because
you want to pace yourself we still
playing cuz here on my friends list so
if he's still playing a week later from
now
week from now we know you're holding
them because I got ice Wars then play
balls back and forth and I just got into
that warm collective man and just not
true though sovereign lifes you're not
playing anthem
until Friday now then I'll play mmm
listen we have some things about there
and you already know we've got the
Incredible Hulk of this aka the XS game
oh the lord of combat sports was a man
of his convictions
that means nothing less than that
premium experience and is the leader of
the fraud alert movement Oh feel of it
Lord King how you doing sir I'm doing
fantastic as you can tell um this has
been a better week from last week little
smiles on my face a whole lot of energy
my man bloody his hair yo when I met him
out in Cali my man is diligent you
understand like he was like your mouse
ah da axis we you act that lion was
definitely rippling it was crazy by the
time he got there so we had already did
the experience so I came out I met my
bro hit him then I hit you with the
t-shirt damn I did I hit you later on no
he hit up later on because after that
yah we're heading out ok yeah
ok yeah so that's yeah so you know we
just like you gonna catch up later
well oh you'll get that shirt that's my
man so this week I've been playing our
black desert which I can't wait to get
it to that topic crackdown so please
game past let that baby loose I was up
in there but it's been Apex all morning
learning my character I've learned that
you have two daddies he wanted a white
Christmas I tell you all the time once I
got this white girl right here I had
this white ghost say saying at the end I
going so just say yeah this is calm yo
y'all see the flavor drip say oh yeah
yeah no fire so um yeah so when you play
apex don't jump from character to
character learn that that one character
cuz I learned that real quickly that you
got a master that dude that he becomes
second nature when you out there
fighting like his supers or here she
supers and and dig like escape moves at
how you work as a team I that I'm really
impressed with this free-to-play game
will give money to pay for you know it's
just it just came out of the blue and I
think it's really a super hit I can't
the biggest thing that I've noticed
about that game is learning at a how to
travel through the mat like it
efficiently and as quick as possible
yeah yeah man it look really clean I
gotta get a credit to it so yeah that's
pretty much it ok yeah topics hey hey
has anyone here been playing that jump
force we go talk about save that bloody
cuz I definitely wanna throw that in
when I'm so job force from the start
that was a thirty dollar game to me
Oh we'll say save it for the end we got
throw that as a bonus definitely I got
you got the enemy King here so we gotta
talk about it so of course you already
know we have the Lord of the cooperative
experience in gaming ninja himself the
shinobi Lord kognito spread never
illness in the realm of the IOP
on the switch on this game you know
what's but that's one of the only zonas
I've never beat like I remember playing
it alot but I don't remember every is
don't we gonna have some fun today at
you
you okay tag-team is our demolition
brothers we won't we gonna go up we're
gonna do this is gonna be a fun like I'm
saying like for the switch to head
what's reaction here but uh yeah but it
looks real good um if your order because
you notice I was waiting King oh they'll
Ubisoft with the 50 I'm like come on man
like they want to bring that price down
I would check wanna shop guys like the
money digit I didn't do the ship stuff I
know that's you guys asked for you and
it do it is implemented ha it's a
one-to-one relationship it's just I
think I can't put that into job bro I
can't oh yes
it alleges station in your cubicle or
your office you gotta have a whole Lab
Oh situation no y'all gotta pay the
bills huh oh oh wow yes hold on
yes yo first of all shout out to stitch
a brother stage six six six nine for the
15 hours oh baby some of you this is for
the cushions that some of you go to
monkey punch right there with it stu-dog
soup chest they need both birthday
bloody red we say that right but if
anyone other than then the people that
we already assumed Lewis how much is
that gonna set everyone everyone because
especially key I was like I don't need
he may not have to bend the knee in ours
because we're gonna find out come April
but you have to admit there's only one
true king and it could be him funny that
day is no I don't think that's that
floki worse than him being the new
actually think about it this way that
day he's going to lose two times because
that day he realized he's gonna kneel
before the one game I'm not feelin how
you guys are butchering Game of Thrones
for me man Kings Wars the column and the
war five kings but this one's going to
right now are you guys gonna join forces
at the end of fight the end yeah
probably at some point you'll bring my
aspect star link for the switch is lit
I'm loving it
yo is literally like a spiritual
successor to Star Fox and the thing
about it that's hot is it got the no
man's sky aspect when you can actually
go up into the planets and go into the
surface all that stuff on the surface do
your mineral you're thinking searching
it's got the Wing Commander vibe where
the people are talking and the starfox
characters are seamlessly integrated
into the story like it's not know add-on
exclusive thing for the switch where
it's not really that really part of it
little fox mccloud there's in this story
yo it is really goodness when they come
out with a April update every time I got
it cuz they come out with April update
there now it's on a direct and y'all
round plate today yo first of all much
appreciated the town expect what we do
if you gotta pay the bills again
absolutely cat daddy fast acts with the
$20 cow cat this all love cat man you
shower listen to Toni Braxton up with
the overall experience there's a reason
they brought the anime king into the
room just wait so later alright I don't
feel like you gonna say Oh
when I when I when you speak when I say
something
I'm the Japanese enthusiast for a reason
right yeah so when I speak about the
Japanese its gospel because the fact
that speak gospel yeah okay why me why
maybe the the person is the most
passionate about it I'm also the one
who's the most critical when I bring
about it so trust me when I talk about
it you're you I'm gonna surprise some
people with my thoughts on you okay now
you to say but we got a long show you
know I do to get yeah yeah all right so
anyway banette gaming vs ex machina
domino on a switch in the bushes
that's your that though you're not the
first person is that right people saying
I don't think it a chance to play yet
it's not so what is it what does it
resemble or just it doesn't look like
it's as fluid is as fast-paced as they
make it out to be yes it's slow it it
just like n64 trying to be there's it's
so bad
it looks so fast but on the switch not
the one I'm not the diversion I got
there demoed at the foot for the foot of
free I don't know why they did that's a
bad look I did yet outstanding pushes
I've been doing anthem just like my
brother bloody doing that getting my
storm on he got him got him out here
looking like Captain Britain from
Excalibur a link up on that 200 no I've
been fine I've been fine have you gotten
food it was okay thank you thank you
what one of the meeting of the booting
you know the only booting I've seen for
some people is that it's when you idle
too long when you sit there especially
if you end up switching to a different
so the game so bad people we want to
move around just been getting booted
just like Bowden move from a lot of Xbox
guys that they've been having issues oh
yeah I've heard they are from
PlayStation dues to the booting has been
going down
how are you hearing from when they
use EA access and what they don't even
have it brother we got actually got that
connects out here like oh here you
talking about the four 360 lover oh one
on PlayStation PS and please be my
friend anyway so that's all I'll be
playing but enough about that log show
so now that we've gotten to what the
Lord's had been playing I want to start
off with Lord bloody knuckles his video
game system history his passion for
comics anime and film and what
eventually led him to creating the smash
and otaku fix podcast so let's start
from the beginning Lord bloody what were
the first video game systems you had and
what got you into gaming oh man so for
me uh and you know I had the prefaces
I'm from the young generation but I have
a love for the classics so growing up my
yeah my cousin's actually had consoles
was actually an S and ass Ness so
growing up I actually was playing on
those consoles in the early 90s for
myself oh I remember fighting the
original Zelda are you playing the
original Super Mario the original contra
like I am I love contra my cousin called
me the beats of contra because I was the
only one who could ever get to the
second alien temple after the snow level
that's once did you like the second
alien like temple though was always the
worst because in fact that's where I
would always die but I was like I can
easily get there without using any
continues I loved it and so I was
growing up with that playing like killer
instinct and stuff and so the the late
nineties when I was probably uh probably
about 8 or 9 and that's when my dad
actually got a ps1 for my aunt so she
gave that to us to have at our house
when she would come to visit and I would
actually play with her so I remember
growing up having the PlayStation 1
although my
self being able to play like spyro crash
I remember playing the the really bad
video game adaptation of die hard and
anyone knows know what's to know my true
history and know that I'm not a fraud
yeah I play the die hard children one
then of course you know had the Nitro
wrestling game WCW wrestling back in the
day
all those classics and I remember
playing you know Metal Gear Michael
actually I watched my cousin played
Metal Gear Solid 1 and that game
affected me back then and cause my love
if you can't tell from my glass right
here i am m GS fancy to the end though
but that was good G Miranda he
introduced world to that to that whole
cinematic I like the contra thing to now
you you actually did your history they
actually put you at that position you
look at you a error of the up down down
left right left right BA see what was
funny is that when when that when I
found out about the Konami code I was
probably about 11 just before the right
when the ps2 was launching right and I
was able to be contra using the Konami
code by only using eight lives so out of
the twenty that they gave you I would be
able to beat it with eight which is only
like a continue if you use the base
three and then getting enough score to
be able to get an extra continue so I
would actually be able to beat that game
with no issues but I was trying to beat
without ever having to use a good
continue so that was always what I
practiced the most of not only in data
chest she's loving you she says good
class he's loving the Metal Gear love
that you've been showing you know say
it's okay so then from there after the
ps1 where did you go to systemize after
after the ps1 I got a I got a Nintendo
64 from a friend and then that was right
when the Gamecube was launching right
alongside the ps2 and I remember I got a
ps2 and the ps2 was absolutely my go-to
for everything because at the time you
know the ps2 was the workhorse console
port for gaming and the in the early
2000s you know it was a DVD player it
was
you know had all the big games coming
out you know Star Wars a star fighter
that was one of my favorite games and of
course you know Mel you're solid too I
remember playing that with my cousin
playing the old gauntlet legends if
anyone ever would remember playing oh
god 'ln legends we will play on our ps2
but every time we would go to the arcade
they had an arcade version we'd all be
huddled around that place I used to
always love like fighting who's gonna
get the golden hammer at each other try
to get each other's hammers try to mess
up everyone's controllers and stuff like
that and if you remember back then oh
especially the PSC had to have the
adapter so that way could turn each port
into like four ports so that way ever
play so I was playing I was doing all
that you know we played a lot of NFL
Blitz back in the day and FL blade Wow
yeah yeah any now from that did you
he'll touch the e360 and all you kind of
stay PlayStation three uh actually no so
coming out of the ps2 era you know I
played all the beginning especially
Kingdom Hearts that was really
solidified because that was actually one
of the first JRPGs besides Final Fantasy
6 I played back on the on this nest that
really solidified my aspect with JRPGs
and I was like 10 and I beat that game
like all the way leveled a hundred got
every collectible I was hardcore into
that game and then coming out of the ps2
era going into the ps3 and 360 was right
when I was going into uh right when I
was going into high school and I didn't
know which console I wanted to go with
at that time and that's actually when I
met some of my closest friends on Xbox
Live way told me to go with the 360
because the fact that that's what
everyone was gaming on that's when I
first found out about online and stuff
like that and when I got the 360 all the
games I ended up playing there changed
my life like I played on a Piton on the
OG xbox from one of my cousins who had a
halo and I loved playing Halo but it
never it never brought me into like
diehard mode right throw the 360 when
I've played gears one here one
absolutely changed
everything from oh let me ask you one
question about is well I'm glad you said
that for me personally I don't know if
you remember this the thing that did it
for me was actually the marketing the
advertisement I think when Ron McCaffrey
had on PETA more and they had like the
head of Xbox was on and it was speaking
to Peter more about when they were
trying to pitch Gears of War in the
boardroom in the marketing campaign and
they talked about this specific trailer
do you remember the cold war trailer
forgives war well cold world Scooby and
they had that like cinematic thing in
the music playing do you remember that
trailer yes yes I do I remember all the
trailers because up to that point I had
been seeing it and it was just after the
the the 360 launch after the ps3 in the
360 and I watched my step-brother in my
and my dad play it hmm uh and I was I
was watching them and I was like oh this
is actually pretty cool but I never
played it until I got my 360 and played
with my my friends at that time and
because of that series eight I literally
the the people I played through that
whole series with mm-hmm
gears 1 2 3 when they added the Ford
player even judgment and for my
roommates literally my best friends and
we're all planning on getting tattoos
together of the Crimson omen with the
world rule and on it oh because of the
fact that it brought us together that
much more on it too oh yeah mmm I think
it was mad world I was a mad world I
forget to be able to swim whatever that
song was that mad world mad world by
Gary Oldman because he did a cover of it
who which the song was originally done
by Tears for Fears back in the ass
people who don't know Yodas young og
right hey we got a respect blood yeah he
doesn't do diligence maybe not like
somebody young generation on a panel he
actually hey you're not wrong in every
every time with you guys and when I talk
with with mega and and lemon shoutout to
those guys from gog is that they always
nice you ate an old so you don't you see
but also he got to old jesus talking to
him you understand likes like when when
he's messing with lemon in them yeah you
know yeah
oh jesus cornutus really pulling them
through because they're actually giving
me props on the the fact of what I
already know yeah yeah that's some good
OG we got to get back together you got
some good old oh jeez to equipment was
just bothering do I so I had to shut
that top drawer apparently they were
going in on it which is fantastic you
know also your calling card has always
been you know the comics the anime the
main like so talk to me about that
passion what I started giving like maybe
some of your favorites that kind of
inspired you to get into that world
oh so when when growing up you know like
a lot of people nowadays my parents
split when I was young when I actually
met or my stabbed my stepdad actually
came into my to my mom's life and stuff
like that he was a good family for a
known for years when he went to his old
house he had me help him pull some stuff
out of his attic right and when I pulled
out some of the stuff from his addict he
actually had a box of old comics I'm
talking like original seventies volumes
of Iron Man the like old school old
school amazing spider-man comics before
it later was rebranded as spectacular
spider-man and then just these
spider-man back in the 90s before we got
ultimate spider-man in the early 2000
where it's at now I remember reading
some of that he had the old Detective
Comics volumes one
through 150 we forgot a cheat sheet
right there you got what we call the
break photographic memory is something
when I when I yeah cuz when I when I
open that box I started reading some
what he had right and it stuck to me
because the fact that he had a lot of
those those oh that he was always a big
mortal fan right so me and him always
had a love for Marvel films we went
seeing all those together but he also
had a massive love for for Batman and
and some of the DC stuff so I remember
reading those and those worlds and
everything just really blew me away so I
grew up reading those uh you know in the
in the mid-2000s and of course you know
I went back to watch all the older
Batman films I watched the original you
know 60s with Adam West
I win watched and I watched all the
original Batman films you know with
George Clooney so yes I know the bat
nipples in the back credits I watched
all of them you know I see I've seen all
those so I've always been a big fan of
those because the fact that I it was
what I got to grow up with and I just
love seeing those what's your birth born
if you're gonna be biased and you're
gonna pick one of the Batman movies that
came out what's your best one to match
the the solo Batman films mm-hmm I would
have to say Batman Forever okay with you
all right certified certified a lot of
people love it no doubt what about mommy
what's your best MCU film currently
raining my best
mc1 right now right now number one still
stands for Mia's Civil War because
that's what we really got that's when we
got the introduction of Black Panther
and everyone else that's what we got to
saw that's when we got to see Winter
Soldier come back and do his thing
and I've always been a Bucky fan because
Bucky's version of Captain America was
always one of my favorites I don't know
no dis to Sam I love Falcon but Bucky
everyone is gonna meet his men
the mantle I don't think he should be
Captain America always found that to be
stupid you know when they gave him the
shield and he flying around in the air
with the shield I'm Zack stupid oh well
what did they call it um whenever uh
they give a black guy a shot and he's
not supposed to get the shot but he's
not he's the what would what affirmative
action yeah you gave a formative action
for the Falcon and I did not appreciate
[Music]
that everybody equal opportunity on
shield crap yeah Bucky is meant to have
it like don't get me wrong I respect
Falcon I love Falcon but him as cat was
never never never worked like don't get
me wrong I liked his costume blunder cap
look it wasn't it wasn't no he's not
meant to carry that mantle I think I
think they need to solidify him as his
own hero as the Falcon Bucky literally
takes over for cat because of the fact
of the bond that him and cap shared and
after the assassination attempt after
the end of civil war and I called this
out after that movie came out is that
Bucky was meant to take over as the man
so but Captain Marvel was meant to lead
afterwards no doubt no doubt but I got a
respect to civil what choice because
also I like that you said with the
introduction of Panther and um Bucky
don't do anything spotty but actually
like the fighting in of Black Panther in
that movie as opposed his own I feel he
didn't get busy enough and I credit that
to the Russos but that's enough so we'll
talk about this whole aspect in the
manga yes the anime aspect alright so
meaning of the young generation I was
actually at the forefront of the anime
movement here in the West you know
growing up in the end of in the late 90s
and early 2000s was when we saw the rise
of it kind of coming over here know it's
all this the start with Pokemon Pokemon
became a global phenomenon over here in
the West as soon as it came over from
Japan everyone loved it
had so many Pokemon things that even my
sisters had something my mom loved it
able to get all through that but we also
saw the coming of classics like Big O
basically Batman in a giant robot
we saw classics like Trigon Gundam
cowboy bebop still women all times you
how crucial one of the biggest shown
over oh yeah
that of course you also had other
classics like neon genesis evangelion
you know another classic mecha that that
really lasts about goes to the shell is
only oh yeah go sinning but remember we
we only in the West we got the TV show
which is stand alone complex we didn't
get the movie until years later
so we be aware of that first but yes
goes to the show was also one of those
those felony aspects as well in it got
your ban for baby you don't know got
your bit
oh no no I grew up watching uh you know
so you watch the original Super Sentai
so I got the seal there and then
probably in the mid-2000s is when they
started showing a little bit of Kamen
Rider so Super Sentai really came over
with that aspect but went back and
showed my my colors watching Robotech
and you know grew up with the original
transformers gen one because the fact
that uh my grandpa collected the old VHS
this is the North Star
I actually caught later but yeah I loved
the North Star going up because Kenshiro
is literally one of the bag is for those
baddest around
gotta love Kenshiro with how caught
ocean can yes parties yes I love that
and then a quick funny story is I didn't
know about Fist of the North Star
growing up and like I when I had the
Genesis I had last battle so I thought
that last battle was the og didn't us
though
Arzak is the truth oh yeah and and then
of course you know I see everyone in the
chat there was some other classics yes
also growing up I grew up with the rise
of Studio Ghibli here in the West
Princess Mononoke grave of the fireflies
Howl's Moving Castle Kiki's Delivery
Service and watch Guyver and I also
watched the original live action of
Guyver
yeah that was actually one of the
coolest things ever because I thought
that that was really dope they did it
really well too yeah
and then of course Akira yes bone slave
yes Akira is still one of the greatest
anime films of all chronic and still
holds up to this day you're a glory
notice the animation in a carer can last
to this day like if you get one right
now it's just as good as some of the
animation movies that they put out right
now year ago some of my roommates had
never seen akira as some of them two of
them are kind of dry or like wishy washy
with anime because the fact that they
have to find one's actually interesting
the other one you know watches a lot of
the bigger shows but i have to tell him
about which ones to watch i set them all
down to watch akira and they were blown
away and i'm like this film is 25 years
old almost 30 years old and still holds
up to this day believe me
yo tremendous anime bro you know facts
and what they i want to conclude also is
that uh you're one of the hardest
working loads right now in the community
you know one thing i want to talk about
is obviously the creation of a smash
podcast and looking with our old friends
good friends at the realm from tick for
the otaku fix podcast so how did you
blink up with that to get that going
both of those going and then also you're
like a panelist on like some real
prominent podcast you know you got tea
the SGP
with lord salty and our boy lord cricket
mega with gog so let's talk about these
podcasts how did all this get so so uh
how that all kind of led is that i was
actually watching you know III found a
few of the people big
the community on YouTube and on on
Twitter about a year and a half ago
probably in late 2017 star just
following people and you started
watching the podcast listening to them
while they lost them in involved and
just like talking the chats here and
there and I do getting to meet Kay mega
offline after listening to grg one time
right and when I when I was talk with
him you know I ended up getting to Adam
one on xbox and talked with him and you
know I was cutting up with him and 100
and some of those guys kind of showing
off you know how passionate I am about
games on my my uh my knowledge and one
day when I joined the party talking with
those guys I got in the middle of a
conversation
kay Meghan hundred was saying that they
wanted to add you know some new blood to
the show as they were getting rid of or
kind of switching things up yeah and as
I joined in all I hear is 100 say watch
me I bloody he's like me like wait what
what about me yeah he just literally
said what you put him in and I was like
wait what what I just jump into he's
like yeah boy he's like what why don't
you come on I was like wait come on for
what he's like won't you come on to an
episode of the gog podcast I was like
yeah I'd be off for that and and you
know a week later he had me on and that
was in October of 2017 I did my first
first ever like podcast debut and that
went well and after that you know I'll
sock will came mega like the next night
he was like everyone really bite cheese
like won't you stay on permanently I was
just like you're not sure so after that
I'm doing that and then I start talking
with some other people who I've been
following in the community and gotten
into party chats with before which was
super G operation gong yeah super og
Supra are gonna make sure
super super yeah oh well I I'm country
I'm southern so you know it's that Supra
really quick quick
Super G I got I got in with him and then
operational Gong Qin and
I'm so kingler we're online we're all in
a party chat with a couple other people
and we're all talking about and this was
shortly after the DN film live-action
came out lat
the summer of 2017 I say DN because I'm
not going to call it by the name that it
was given because it does not deserve
that name but let's just say that
live-action for an anime adaptation was
god-awful completely completely true and
we were literally sitting there like
ripping it apart as everyone was
watching it in the party chat together
and we started talking about anime and
they're just like wait are we still
gonna start an anime podcast or like
this sounds like an anime podcast you
know what I was like let's do it and
they're just like oh yeah wait who's
gonna who's gonna host it and they're
just like well why don't you do it I was
like you know ya know so come come the
end of October is when I officially
started this vash podcast with those
guys and we've been running ever since
and it's it's just been a wall ride and
because of my up-and-coming knowledge
with that as being an anime eccentric
and a japanese enthusiast along with
having a premiere on grg and then later
getting invited by salty who had heard
kanji orgy a few times invited out to do
a few episodes of tea sgp and then later
inviting me on as a permanent panel
member i just started getting a lot of
recognition that's how I ended up
meeting you guys
because I actually didn't episode first
with David who came out there on TS GP
one episode and then a couple weeks
later almost a month
kognito you came on to me and even
started talking and then we all started
talking in the d-ends and that's not
when right before me and you ended up
you invited me out for the for the
destiny episode all the about a year ago
and just after all that and after III of
my kind of upcoming and the guys from
tick over there and cow so much respect
to him he came out he came to me and
said hey I want to start he's like we
had an anime podcast on the on the on
the website he's like it didn't work out
but he's like I only have one writer for
for the for the network and stuff like
that he's like I want you to partner
with him on this no we want to reach out
to that demographic and he's like and we
want people who actually know about that
and you know
that was sure that was shortly after I
got the moniker the anime king like
everyone started coming with me about
all that stuff I felt humbled when they
when they asked me say hey you're the
most prominent about this in the
community we want you to start this
project and I was just like you know
what yeah I'm all for it so me and JD
started talking we got it going and then
they reached out to me and say hey once
you become an official partner with us
doing this project and that really
showed to me just how much is a short
time a lot of people have come to know
me as well as see the knowledge and kind
of my passion about everything I've
talked about it's really good to see
because we all see your passion
absolutely bumped into you out at e3 we
bumped into you with many podcasts and
that's one thing that resonates so it's
good to see in this short period of time
just based on your hard work and your
passion and also the lane that you have
I feel it's such a unique Lane and it's
really underrepresented so to see you
out here moving is shakin with the big
dogs and the industry and getting you
getting you just do is really cool so
I'm proud man well keep that that rocket
going man it's amazing that to hear
those words about that because like when
I met yella at e3 especially last year I
was only doing smash and on grg for
about six months seven months and I'm
only doing GTS GP for almost five months
and I'm just like I'm at the one event
that dreamed of since I was a kid he's
in love with with gaming I'm just like
how did my my life just starting with
all that rooftop brother you're for the
big dogs baby you see it was a shot
Megatron to chat he was up there we are
GOG we are the weather's even in May as
well
you guys are and we have we have a scene
see the pictures that that
that you posted up and of course David
we were up there hanging out with Mike
Ibarra go hope you started hanging out
with some of the other execs the next
night at the at the downtown bar like it
was it was crazy man it was a fun time
shout out the Megatron on that whole
putting it together definitely much love
Megatron I was great meeting you can't
wait for this year to Menace history man
let's finish it off I gotta ask you the
question that I asked all the guests of
the realm long blood
I need top five video games or
franchises of all time
oh okay so because the fact that it had
the biggest effect I mean I'm a massive
fan of it I have to say number one is
Metal Gear Solid I mean it helped people
that some of the stuff that I have
around and some of the tattoos I have
planned I'm very much a Kojima fan
number two number two was definitely
Gears of War because it gave me some of
the the best friends that I've had and
the closest family that I've had
throughout throughout gaming you were
three great ways was contra because
literally I remember going to the arcade
when I wasn't playing at my cousin's I
would actually go to the arcade that was
in our neighborhood and would actually
play it on the old-school arcade
machines there you know with all the
classics like Galaga and stuff like that
you know old donk old Donkey Kong back
arcade so I loved playing that you know
before is Tekken because ii three was
one of the first fighting game that i
played back on the PS warrior that one
has stuck with me since okay perfect
conversion yeah features originally my
character was king i used back in the
day but way back then thought you just
made up a hang-up so yeah because so yes
king was my man back then because the
fact of that that was one of my favorite
characters become six when that came out
I fell in love with Dragunov Draganov
became my boy because
Russian style Samba I have one question
for you did you know how to pull off the
role in death cradle Oh Oh seesaw you
want another level with that I knew how
to do it I just could never get it to
connect half the time because when that
was when that was out when I really got
into fighting games thanks to my to my
step-brother at the time is that I was
practicing a lot trying to get that
right when I was learning how to use
them and I practiced it so much I was
like yeah I could do it every time I was
in a fight I could never connect it and
listen let me tell you something about
something it didn't matter where you
were it didn't matter what she was
trying to do he knew how to cancel
whatever you was doing and put you in
there rolling yeah crazy yup he's so
nice with that character but I was
ashamed that he's jumped from that
character went to Brian theory and was
equally as dangerous yes and Brian was a
beast because the fact that once I moved
called the rolling death cradle yeah
rolling at crazies extremely he could be
losing the entire match it's that grab
off if you have to sit through ten
animations of your man getting mangled
it then you let his legs spread eat it
up in the air is that why they started
doing those break combo things there's
only certain points during the combo
where you're buggy
when I started I said okay you he go get
this I don't care what school I'm gonna
memorize the move to that it stops the
ending part of the rolling death crater
where you just watch your life just
evaporate then he changes it up yeah so
he knows that you gonna try it right
there and he'll do the alternative ones
yeah disrespect you more like it was
such a guessing of what related playing
against off in Tekken so pretty much
like the first time you use his own you
look like that Pikachu mean if I can't
you if I catch you right at the start of
the match it's over yeah and and what's
worse about is that that when people
come up against King players especially
if they really know
how to use Kings and he knows how to go
from those grapples and to everything
you're almost never gonna get out of it
you let him if you let him get any one
of those like quick grapples in it's
done for because he can go on from the
from the slam straight into a roll right
over and then get your leg then we rock
up it to the body slam you ain't getting
out of it check it out
citizen to chat citizen he knows what
I'm talking about we oughta Taekwondo
kick characters when you take I take
swore on my second character because of
because peplum ingo stance yes
this switch up with the Flamingo stance
you can switching up from cakes all the
time yeah his punches were very quick
but the way that he would flip into
those going into flamingo sense even
though you're hopping on one leg and
people try to go for those low kicks to
trip you up the way that he can quickly
go into a kick down and then go right
back into it no Vic the counter people
but his character specifically had kick
counters it nullified a huge part of our
office so you have to throw punches with
him so it is such a mental missing game
oh you just run back hey hey that's why
I tell you that's what people don't
always say is that right my passion goes
across I love it for my number 5 in
front of a fire for the last one I would
have to say one of the the franchise's
that probably left one of the second
biggest impacts or one of the last
biggest impacts for me that has kind of
transcended would definitely be would be
Tom Clancy and especially the Rainbow
six series because the fact that I
remember playing some of the older Tom
Clancy games and I remember playing
Splinter Cell but it wasn't until really
Rainbow Six Vegas 1 I got completely
drawn in by the realistic military
shooters and I remember that one right
because it was all first-person shooter
all the way through up until when you
have
to blind-fire right you hold the left
trigger back on the ps2 and the and the
the or the the P the 360 controllers and
all that stuff right and you would
actually see your character model up
against the the cover so you get that
third person shooter to be able to blind
fire around corners like that so I
always fell in love with realistic
military shooters after that by Tom
Clancy I remember reading a lot of the
books and stuff like that Advanced
Warfighter yeah like all those I
remember reading a lot of those series
you know tremendous business where the
best for me I'm Percy I'm biased cuz I
like your telephone five was definitely
lit and it's very unique I like when
people grab the top five and it's not
generic yes so diversity is just normal
does anything wrong with that
I love Zelda growing up and I love Mario
and I played all those games but I was
like I played them they didn't have that
those effect on me like like d-series it
like I said I love the Final Fantasy
series but you know everyone was playing
seven when that came on the ps1 that
seven wasn't my was it my all-time
favorite final fantasy no that was six
and six is the one that really sold me
on on JRPGs because the fact that you
actually had a villain who succeeded and
was actually legitimately terrifying
because kefka is probably one of the top
villains of all time and I will stand by
that addicts want to fight let's move on
we'll fight but anyway results are in
and the people have spoken to the
question with the surprise reveal and
tremendous success of Apex legends for
respawn and Electronic Arts which EA
franchise do you feel has the most to
lose now based on this release the
winner of the four way poll at 43% was
the battlefield 5
storm who's gonna I payed big battle
royal DLC now group coming in at second
place at 25% was that I don't care
fortnight is finally thrown in the
bushes a razor coast third place at 23%
was the anthem apex release date is too
close and can affect their momentum
group and sadly at last place at only
the opposite was the spinoff when will
Titan for three release group so shout
to all the Lord tells me oh give it to
solve Lord I mean I agree I think who's
gonna play for a battlefield battle
royal now like it's no it makes no sense
like in the short term I can see how it
affects it might take eyes off of anthem
just because somebody might might be
like you know what I'm not I pay for
this right now what I have something for
me I can play so yeah it doesn't make a
lot of sense but the games are very
different yes so it's just a matter of
taking attention away from it rather
than it sort of usurping it as that type
of game because it's not that type of
game so I think in the long term yeah
it's just battlefield was done in in
that regard unless it's something they
come out with some modes or something
that are super different and super
unique I don't see it making a dent
against this stuff and yeah I do think
if this training he's rolling I mean
again fortnight is a special thing right
what I don't know man we'll see we'll
see how the how the generation ends off
if this thing keeps rolling and I hope
that respawn has really looked at epics
model for updating fortnight like right
now in fortnight apparently there's some
cracks in the world that people don't
know what the hell they are you this is
what I'm talking about like it keeps
people interested in the world because
they're already starting to load in
Valentine's Day content some right there
they're already looking at that which is
kind of what why they're ahead of the
curve right now by looking at battle
royale and we can we can kind of give
anthem a lot of a lot of flack one way
or the other but I think Bioware knows
what they are trying to do for ya people
are gonna say hey it doesn't have PvP
but they they're looking at
the the the power fantasy that destiny
had early on and focusing on this the
the PvE content and I think that they've
looked at enough
what updates with with those kinds of
styles from them to warframe and others
to see what they need to do so now it's
just really both of these games the
biggest aspect while they have the
appeal right now is will time well will
they be able to stick to full time show
that they could stick 200 will they not
cuz respawn right now literally has all
eyes on them with how big apex has
become in just over two weeks right you
know and a week they did a quarter of
what took a year for fortnight to get
they pulled a lot of the fortnightly I
do think when it comes to that if apex
would came out first you would had a
similar result that you saw before at
night yeah all the eyes on fortnight you
know it was easier to get that kind of
traction the reason that that that was
is because fortnight has really gone
into the be are seen unabated even when
blackout came or right and I was for I
did while it was definitely good and was
a solid product it didn't have the
longevity to compete with fortnight
because of what one big reason right and
that's because you had to pay to get
into it you had to buy black do you
people try to sit here and be an
apologist we're fine we're fine with a
game having no with this I'm just saying
if we're gonna be calling now let's call
it out and we're calling out not having
PvP that we should be calling out every
game that doesn't have a PvE we see this
is the thing you put in a game that's
inside of genrih but you're saying we're
gonna exclude what's the norm for every
game in that genre okay huh the
borderlands Borderlands is not a
but is it not a little older you go is
not a little shooter okay Tom Oh Tom oh
stop stop it you know for a fact anthem
is made up as an MMO right or wrong it
hit it let's get started
no MMO or not could you keep talking
about destiny is also MMO light broke it
is in row let's let's get to the real
base attacks of this
I don't yes right so the fact that
you're trying to associate it with its
superior why doesn't it have the same
things and it's coming years later
here's the thing they won one of the
biggest things that they that if they do
that as they have to look at what
destiny is doing wrong because destiny
if you look at the PvP side well it has
it affects the PvE because the fact that
their system their entire engine they
don't know how to separate the two not
like a game like World of Warcraft all
right
the World of Warcraft has built no no no
no war the Warcraft has separate
balancing issues for the equipment for
PvE and raiding content compared to
their PvP and the arena Bungie never
knew how to properly negotiate the the
effects of affecting PvP and PvE right
why don't the game out when it's good
when is all together like why not ship
it when it's got what is cooked like
who's selling half baked cakes who the
hell wants to buy a half baked pie like
who don't want the crust on a pie crust
oh my
I walk across and you know no I want to
look at a dude and we'll be able to
punch him in the mouth
I want to get him like Joe we're gonna
lose our handle is see you you gotta
understand this anthem look why is this
the anthem slender pocket like I said
before reach out to Eric's and we're
going to start that freelanced already
bought this for you all bloody because
he's on your zone you know it was right
it was he brought that up and then he
did the apologist thing and I'm like I
can't go anywhere now I got calling me
baby but again that's all right here we
go so to these topics and after we know
the Nintendo Direct was recent this week
st. a a lot of stuff to break down a lot
of impression is there really a lot of
stuff so pretty much you know we want to
talk about that and I wanted to bring
the situation first um obviously what
was displayed and then I'm gonna link it
into part two of this discussion so the
first part let's talk about what you
know some of the highlights of what was
displayed and kind of the release window
of what's going on with Nintendo right
now so one of them in March fees we're
gonna get uh Yoshi's crafted world you
know I'm saying April we're gonna have a
lot of release to existing games our
download releases as far as our smash
brothers get the spring update
I believe our box boy and Boxberger girl
get something as well all June Super
Mario maker 2 which is a huge one a lot
of people were waiting for them July
we're getting Fire Emblem the three
houses you that I'm saying and Dragon
Quest builders to August my game early
game of the Year nominee I'm with you
there alright so that's my early low
pick and there for me personally again
another one for summer we're getting our
Marvel Ultimate Alliance three
you're insane so we getting that and
then full of four we get an Animal
Crossing Luigi's Mansion three has
already been confirmed we should get a
guaranteed Pokemon RPG not a light not a
letter Sam yeah commencing and stuff
that wasn't mentioned in the red I know
I'm going I'm gonna let you go for that
but then which surprised a lot of people
was the legend of zelda links awakening
yeah remake you don't I mean so that was
a huge and then we heard that um
Nintendo is publishing the Dragons quest
eleven port with a ton of exclusive
features only to the switch so basically
what I say is to say this so we round
this up based on everything that was
released and I skipped a whole bunch do
you dig the round table that the switch
is now poised to dominate MPD and naman
[ __ ] like they did in 2018 all over
again in 2019 and better the Xbox and
Playstation again so I'm gonna bring it
to Lord bloody first did you catch this
direct did you you know it based on what
you saw didn't see you know what your
expectations coming in for the switch in
2019 when I when I want when I went back
cuz I watched it after right so I try to
steer away from all news so I went back
and actually watched wells at work and
every a lot of what they announced has
me excited or the switch because right
now I we have a switch in our house
right it's my roommates we shared we
share we we've all played in stuff like
that
this year's lineup especially with some
of the other games I already out
you may want to go and buy my own switch
for my donors because if you can't see
over here I have my ex I have my I have
my ps4 I have stuff and a couple my
other consoles my ps3 my 360 LM sorry I
know my switch is definitely gonna be on
my bi list because of two big games
Link's Awakening was absolutely one of
my favorites but right sick right behind
a Link to the Past links to the past is
still my all-time favorite Zelda but
Link's Awakening I'm absolutely excited
for him when they announce that remake
we already heard rumors about it for for
a while now and when they actually
confirmed that I was getting a full
remake that's great to see and I was
excited for that but the biggest thing I
was truly excited for was a proper
sequel for Fire Emblem
we haven't gotten one the last one that
came out on the greediest yes we had the
one that they released on mobile which
was you know it was alright it was it
had the fireman appeal but you know it
was a mobile game they had you know the
microtransactions and all that stuff and
it was fun but I've been wanting an
actual Fire Emblem and when they made
the announcement of the Nintendo Direct
and made that the big name that they
were putting out first I was all excited
for that because I loved tactical RPGs
if anyone has involved in my mixer I've
been playing through about carrier
Chronicles I love the tactical RPGs Fire
Emblem is one of those ones that I
absolutely love to this day and I'm
excited for that that makes me want to
go get my mileage but Super Mario maker
everyone has played through the original
Super Mario maker doesn't matter whether
you're just playing or people who are
creating that game was so big because of
the non-stop creativity of of that
community then of course after we
already got the announcement a few
months ago for Marvel Ultimate Alliance
3 the black order for Nintendo I was
excited for that I had I played the
original to Marvel Ultimate Alliance is
back on the 360 sad we never got 31 but
congrats to Nintendo getting getting
that as an exclusive I'm excited for
that
all huge absolutely huge Astro chain was
definitely that that caught me off guard
and I'm excited for that maybe when I
get to go save that well don't go too
I wouldn't believe he probably hates it
just like everyone who who hated on was
it Halle night because that was on
switch only before a couple months later
unlike yourself I have a switch so I
don't know that I actually have a switch
so I can actually talk on what's good
what's not secondhand usage let me
recall from firsthand experience all
right because you are a prospective
purchaser are you going to the store so
those are my guy let's get to the part
of the ownership this is the owner part
ownership look at this fancy thing I my
kids play it though my kids play not
really in a second oh no Museum more
than you are they definitely are but
they know who owns it kognito you know
when you walk in the room somebody
playing your stuff you can walk over and
play thank you
saving his penis it's a perpetual fear
of day walking in the war machine so but
I do think that game looks very nice
even the even a chat saying your
switches on the closet over on the case
you are big attacked so finish them as
far as those are stuff that really
impressed you but also in conjunction to
the overall picture for 2019 with lineup
do you feel that the switch is poised to
dominate NPD the way they did 2018 over
Xbox and places absolutely here's the
thing they have their first party lineup
see well-well 2018 was a little bit you
know drive throughout the year up until
the end when they had you know Smash
Brothers come out which absolutely sold
consoles that game hard to get you
couldn't find adapters for an for the
game controllers or any of the random
yet yeah but it completely pushed you
know switch tails absolutely that game
had in numbers for for for Nintendo
because we knew it was you know they had
they had a slower year but like 2017
when they came out the gate with Odyssey
when they came out the gate with with of
course Zelda and all their strong first
party lineup it showed 2018 not as
strong but still they had a lot of the
the third part they were starting to get
third-party support and they had the
Andes that were really big throughout
the year this year they have a lot more
coming out of the first party again and
that's going to show because the fact
that you saw a game like Super Mario
maker the half Fire Emblem you have CEO
she but of course he
have the big things that people are
waiting for they have the Pokemon RPG
that a lot of people want they don't
want the Pokemon light what light they
got would let's go Pikachu like they got
with let's go Eevee they were well that
helped to sell and push for the mobile
market to buy a switch it wasn't selling
anyone on an actual switch themselves
except for those people but now they're
actually getting a full dedicated
Pokemon game they're getting there's
already still the talks of a new animal
planet that's still supposed to be
coming up or animal yeah yeah animal
I loved Animal Crossing I love animal
crossing I played on GameCube I had it
on though the way I had it on the ds2
3ds I played you know pocket camp Animal
Crossing is absolutely one of the games
that I'm looking for it that's coming
out following it does it really does
have a huge following and you know those
are games that are gonna help push this
for that as well as Luigi's Mansion 3
well Luigi's Mansion has always been one
of those hit or miss for some people it
still has that following and it's one of
those strong first party games that will
help cool people so their first party
lineup is really set to show what the
switch has coming for this year
especially after this Nintendo Direct no
no man so I so thought these with some
would solve in a cocktail for Oh Lord
addict mm-hmm how you been feeling about
that the attendance was direct what did
you see what did you anything that
caught your attention and then obviously
the bigger overall question do you think
switch is poised to dominate 2019 all
over again I think the director is a
good direct mm-hm
I think that's I don't know pokemons
gonna do again we're Pokemon did last
year we Pokemon and Super Smash Brothers
I think that's what made it go over the
spider-man cells if Animal Crossing
comes out this year that doäôt so
everything mm-hmm as of right now they
got a lot of good games but I don't know
if they have any switch cellar games mmm
ok Sokka Mary that's one thing I was
gonna say is like a lot of their first
party lineup not all of it but a lot of
our system seller type games like Mario
you know you're getting a bundle with
that yes
no Zelda I'm sure they'll try to find
some sort of wavy I don't know how big
open s oh yeah an S because I don't
think it's a 1:1 remake III think they
were expanding on that game that game
was it was long but it to me I dig them
do something else with that game
if crossing comes out this year I would
say a bundle aim to elbow some of these
console owners animal Crossing's
probably one of their biggest IVs it
really is and anyone who denies that is
as kids while we could look at why we
didn't look at animal crossing and say
you know who would play this game animal
crossing has big one of the biggest
following since it premiered on the
Gamecube the question what we know we
don't know if Luigi's Mansion is coming
out this year yet I don't go until I see
like a solid release like something like
a time frame the fact that you know we
might see some Luigi's Mansion at e3 it
depends on what they do a Pokemon now
they could go give us that you know the
hard RPG that they say they are or they
can look at the cells they made off
Pokemon go let's go and like we're gonna
do that - here - yeah and Nintendo will
do that if they see money in it and
we're just talking about software we're
not even taking in consideration the
fact that if that smaller construe the
mini if that is true the games have been
walking away from their motion crap
mm-hmm animals passing comes out this
year I can totally see them out selling
if it does that they still can because I
do think you know Link to the Past
that's that's gonna Oh link to the past
remake I would be throwing my money so
fast because Link to the Past so the
greatest Zelda for me all the time you
know they they already have the Zoda
that's already going to be coming out
this year yeah yeah no addict you
actually agree
I don't have stuff that's right now
yes you don't see it happening unless
unless what he comes out this year all
right so I give it like a 50% she's
confirmed it's confirmed as a full
release I have the article right now
they just recently announced animal
crossing I don't see it out there it's a
release date good I mean yeah we've only
seen that game one time we didn't even
see game play I don't think so for the
four that is supposedly I'll say
supposedly announced for for Animal
Crossing Luigi's Mansion three pokemons
the standard poking around RPG and
legend of zelda links awakening remake
those are supposed to be full releases
for this year I get again anything I'm
not gonna give him Animal Crossing - I
see a more defined day because you know
all the other ones of Link's Awakening I
don't see them having an issue with any
kind of development time with that one
but we've only see Animal Crossing one
time we've seen Luigi's Mansion once but
it was a good amount of time ago so
yesterday I saw everything if it doesn't
50% chance I think I know why you know
and it's going to my topic a little bit
but Shawn was kind of clear in his
interview that they kind of don't have
much to talk about other than stuff
they've already talked about oh thank
you master
mods gave this our brother manopause
brother he said well $10 super chat if
the big end releases switch meaning he
may get it
much money you willing to spend how much
you willing not to spend like your
average game this year yes is the third
party kind of weak right now quiets like
this year there normally that would hurt
switch because they're not getting you
know the metros and stuff but like okay
over there like third party in general
is just not that strong
see it's not gonna hurt them as much
once these games don't come out for
their cause though he's gonna be honest
okay so because they said and they say
Pokemon bingo I lost my I gotta
following yeah they do and you alright
so unis incoming no damn Xbox get out of
here so but I see this right I love to
direct I loved it I say yo I said you
know what I really like about the Rex I
like they didn't really direct you
didn't really about this they didn't do
it very nice they control the narrative
was fantastic they showed you all the
stuff that nobody else does not have de
stuff exclusive stuff and they all
so showed you a time frame that they was
putting the games in the summer time but
what they didn't show you was they damn
sure didn't show you Apex
all anthem or anything else that's on
these big guys so they showed you little
boy stuff they say hey check this out
being it you can't play all that great
stuff like Metro how about did you see
the Assassin's Creed at this point good
no way I would say the majority of
people that would be buying a switch
this year already have another contour
y'all not talking about the bad stuff
that was on their screen on his own
Island all that stuff is irrelevant to
the switch not getting you're gonna tell
me that the fact that they're not
getting Apex legends or they're not
getting anthem is really gonna hurt them
then you're lying so what they did
before like listen to me this is what
I'm talking about the kool-aid is being
drunk and all right handing out kool-aid
people are drinking it but I understand
this fact the times that they're
dropping games is when there is a desert
for video games now at this point Sony
is closing down you spend is no desert
for video game Kingdom Hearts and and
summertime is when there is this really
no games being dropped but they're
dropping games in the summertime summer
is gonna be lit with a switch to be fair
to be fair soft I had to agree with
David on this one is that so no no no to
be fair big releases for all the big
consoles summertime is literally the
most dry because now we're certain with
seeing the fall and winter season always
been the big seller and now we're
starting to see some of the early spring
trying to go but here's the counter last
year right when they kind of
with predicting this huge fiscal year
and it wasn't kind of happening and
until the very end in December it was
doing act like it was the summer that
one moment dominate a good amount of
people that bought a switch last year
had the in mind that smash was coming
out in December yeah but this year is
gonna be a little you don't have a
domino effect this year but if Animal
Crossing comes out of telling could be
similar result there's no real
exclusives coming for the other two okay
so you know these guys third parties
that's out either so right here right
here for you third party that's like you
see oh that's a game of the year do we
have it right people won't announce
there's not that juggernaut that's
coming out - true true true but in it
but see and then I'd Zelda what sealed
the deal for me was that Zelda when I
saw it because I came out of the blue
that this isn't what Nintendo's known
for this season opportunities stuff that
they used to let slide before they're
actually grabbing these opportunities
and actually putting games and putting
our butts on controllers I feel it I
feel what they're doing I understand
what they're doing I respect what
they're doing I'm only gonna play the
games that are real exclusive games that
I like now yeah I know you said that
changing
I gotta see more on it you look nice I'm
not a big play draw you're gonna add
like it wasn't remorse in that direct it
was what was it like all night on that
on that kool-aid like you guys wore when
you saw that game I saw that I was like
let's make don't give me that because it
looks better than scalebound look
games is on that I make one good game I
make four straight games that game look
like the best joint Dave dropped in like
three or four yeah I'm gonna raise you
they're also making Bayonetta three I'm
not gonna lie though that Bayonetta
three I'm almost four Bayonetta because
who but their forces yeah that's what
hurts a lot of companies is that they
they do too many projects or James right
now yeah that's also also right now for
you guys right here I got I got a little
joke for you this is what Nintendo is
saying with all the games that they were
showing off especially showing that uh
that summer released right they're
saying this right here they saying I
want you look at that I want you right
now that's what they want you to do they
want you to go out and buy that sweater
Carol they're not shout out to match
they're not bind until they drop it it
to honey get off that price they still
got we use out there for hours yeah yeah
to be fair though it doesn't go down a
little bit it's all video yep
yeah what's up what do you feel about
this like I say like like they wait from
from Sony's part we honestly may only
get days gone and dreams is here maybe
that's a real cop I've been told like
99% chance ghost is coming this year
okay Wow so that that was much further
along then and then we thought well
that's a that's a talking point but it
has it been confirmed although I
wouldn't put it past sucker punch and
I'm really looking forward to that game
because Sucker Punch does have a I
really do enjoy a lot of what they did
people really don't know all the the
true history of sacrifice I only known
for infamous but people forgot they also
did this like who
Cirie's way back in the day sir well and
then then the same with Microsoft we
haven't really heard anything specific
about what's coming this year a lot of
that new stuff probably not singing
until the next gen so yeah this is a
prime time for them to dominate if they
have something big but but I can't we
can't knock Microsoft just yet I mean
definitely they are prepping for the
next generation but we asked you what we
got what happens that they pull a wild
card and the next Xbox comes out holiday
this year but I say it's way too early
for them do that I've been saying I buy
that 2021 is the year that it's gonna
come out no I think it's coming up next
if 2017 was a mid gen refresh and that
was four years you gotta look three to
four years out 2021 is gonna be the
perfect time yeah and maybe it doesn't
matter what the mid refresh if so he's
coming out next year they're coming out
next year they're not getting you you
you try to get your knees chopped off
again you trying to go in again hey if
I'm already on my way Bendis over and I
ain't got a problem with getting more
leases when you grow back the pair to
take knees I think outside feel path on
the podcast bloody because I heard a bit
oh you believe that Microsoft will wait
a whole year let Sony come out you think
if Sony comes out next year Microsoft is
gonna come out in 2021 I need I'm gonna
I'm gonna point this at you because the
fact that I'm gonna I just want to wait
and there's a good reason right because
it right now Sony while they have these
two games coming out they haven't said
or have anything that they could say is
going to come out for the next console
even for the next generation and they
come out next year what the hell are
they gonna put out for it
what they're gonna do as they're either
gonna do cross cross-gen games like we
did for the 360 and the ps3 era into the
to the current generation like we saw
with games like that or they're gonna
have to go back with three masters okay
cool let's check it out what's up with
these knees go you keep talking me baby
not yet you're not giving my take is
that Microsoft will not allow them to
launch and then they don't launch in the
same year if not the same month or week
in which they release so your take is
that they will actually allow them to
the drop and they will come next year so
my thing is I want your lead into this
corner
stand behind your conviction I will
stand by this because I'm good thank you
as early as they want if they don't have
anything yeah they can get the early
sales but if Microsoft comes out with a
console it has a strong line-up those
early sales are going to flip-flop and
go for something that actually appeals
to them all right let's move on back to
the switch look you could take one knee
come April and then we'll talk about the
other knee later you finished up with
your ejects I gotta jump in man yeah man
I mean honestly everything else like
they got announced like this urn things
that I know are gonna just sell better
on the switch that blood-stained rich of
the night gonna sell best on the switch
um yes
what was your the delta rune thing to
undertake the undertale thing which is
free that's cool
oh another thing that people haven't
really talked about but it's actually
very good is that damn free Tetris 99
that tetris battle royale silly works
that that made me laugh right that gets
that rare that I got in there and it
works and a lot of people people I mean
Tetris is I was hatred hey everybody
showed me his wife's playing oh they
blame people are really really playing
that game free Oh to be fair it's Tetris
man as you said this is the perfect game
and then uh a little disappointing was
the final fantasy stuff because the the
version of nine that actually came out
that same day is just the old iOS
version it which never was great to
begin with um
but is there so I don't know that's for
me yo switch gags dead like I don't want
you to guys but I think I got a double
one man I think they got another one I
won't be honest like I had no
expectations for this direct and in my
opinion this was III level like at
classic the franchise's exclusive bang
is for me personally once I saw a Marvel
Ultimate Alliance wing the Captain
Marvel and the defenders in I seen I am
visited that were the whole thing's been
drop out co-op the online I'm saying and
it's made by team ninja Oh Sasha okay
you want me on that off alone I didn't
have to watch a show no more that was
just my personal selfish game I won't
follow lines then they got the dragon
quest 11 you know I'm saying we're all
which exclusive they look fire you
already know how I feel about StarLink
they had the DLC with all that stuff
they got fire Emlyn I'm calling Fire
Emblem Harry Potter edition all part of
the joint but it's traditional cuz I
really don't like to other emblems
that's kind of like the dynasty warrior
I knew you know Sam and there what's
that Square Enix game with the souls in
a day and it's going back and forth
forgot it got a name with a hole in it
I forget the name I can look really cool
so well people bid on that yeah you mean
you were talking about only nah I don't
I don't like the fact that they went
away from what they'd done like they're
completely trying new stuff now it's
great it's just publishing it yeah same
people who made um uh man what's that
game yeah I mean I'm all for it like I'm
looking forward to the getting new games
that they got coming out and next
maaan I just want to provide a default
no that's all I care oh yeah bravely
default that we need more knocking but
for me right now as it stands right down
by both anticipated game is that astral
che by platinum gazes with yo that's
looking City you know cold veins a
little Akira motorcycle action yes going
on then he had to do a play mechanics
with the weird mystical chick bra yeah
look crazy me they let you get any
bloody but here's the thing they got the
dude from Bayonetta on it mmm-hmm they
got the directed that's gonna direct to
do for me I don't model on it like
they've got a crush talent on this game
and it's coming out this year's summer
beyond I you know I'm saying and we all
know these are releases now we still got
three on deck as long as they don't
fumble the ball because in my opinion
with the ball that you I know smash with
smash and I just didn't need a smash
directed III yeah you're gonna get a
smash directed III an Animal Crossing
comes out this year I can almost
guarantee you that whole thing's will be
dedicated if they do it they'll still
win I just personally hope that they
show up a little bit more that's in
their bag as far as the heavy hit is not
just do a whole Pokemon direct you know
I'm see at the end of the day they do
these a lot so they don't need to show
all their bag yeah what but here's
here's the thing about that right yeah
they do a lot of these but typically
here's what when a Nintendo Direct looks
like right it's 30 minutes long you have
25 minutes of fluff and [ __ ] and
that comes out from them the whole time
and then the last five minutes is
something that completely blows everyone
away I agree with it you know not
something good
they don't always even open it with
something good said oh it's just a lot
of the directs they've opened with goods
that they opened a Luigi's Mansion they
opened with what did they open with this
time they opened with something good
this time to I can't remember off top
but I mean listen at the end of the day
you know they can choose to do a
breakdown on Pokemon I'm not gonna like
there's gonna be a ton of people that do
because people want that pokemons RBG I
still feel they got a lot in the chamber
they've taken still release and I think
they could dominate this thing all over
again man that's just me personally but
astral train is my number one
anticipated game of 2019 that's how
amazing that game looks to me I'm
willing to bet you that game we gotta
get going anyway talked about crackdown
all right so let's get the crackdown
says I'm you to the knees first Hey look
by the end of it you're good now you're
gonna have so many Me's you have to
switch up two elbows apparently we gonna
move all because I heard one word that
right there party crackdown 3 the
aftermath in these gaming streets what's
going on alright so for those of you
that know cracked up came out last
Friday there's blood in the streets
that blood is crackdowns below ground I
think this I think crackdown was trying
to play not any on ways to die but uh
you know first on who here's played it
did you like it
yeah do you think it justifies like you
know the four five six out of tens you
ready okay all right now the hell with
anybody the system will talk about talk
bad about the game let's talk about a
single-player experience first because
that multiplayer stuff that was some
add-on crap that they got locked and it
that that's a weird story within itself
but that single-player put up any one of
those first two crackdowns put it up
against it the game looks better it runs
better has better population has better
aiming better shooting um what the
verticality in the game is ridiculous
the collectibles is there the game is a
crackdown game the story is fantastic
the the enemies is fun um the game is
fun if the game is exactly what they
said it was gonna be and it's for is for
K thirty so if somebody's sitting out
there
talking crap about either they don't
have our X or they don't have a 4k
television my course is going to look
like the old stuff that you got the old
stuff going at this game like his crap
this game is definitely certified
working-day uh King King is it is this
is this King approved is this iron and
and they don't need to be paying full
price and people actually paid attention
to anything that's going on it's on the
damn dashboard you can get two months
for two bucks what are you doing alright
you paying two bucks for that game what
a clarify kicks David so they were all
clear put some fires in the chat
therefore for King David fires in the
chairs can't experience the way it did
is the gamers fault because they are
broken they cannot afford to clear yo
[ __ ] i'm definitely going out those
broke gamers out here talking mad crap
like you if you actually got the game
and you got a 4k television and you
gonna put it up against something else
you gonna tell me don't look better than
that other game i don't wanna hear what
you're talking about bro if you sitting
there playing on a simple you got a su
so what you might if you're playing what
you're saying is because people haven't
been premium enough to enjoy crackdowns
right why are you playing don't wanna
hear it's 4k so you beat it yet no I
haven't but you can look at
yes you see me I know you how did you
like it okay
everybody's talking about the
multiplayer right now they said you can
play with your friends hey you knew
something was up and they said here's
the main game and here's race oh I'm
talking the bone and Chris in the chat
and he was like yeah it's true so I'm
playing the first one like it was crazy
this is fantastic looks amazing Oh tsk
you like this oh my god like they don't
know what's going on on my side I'm just
going crazy over the game we is King
bought a new house that check didn't
kill the game as I played the game
before and it look like crap before and
it actually looks good now so then when
I put in the multiplayer I said oh I see
why is it separately but they never lied
to you
it's gonna be real concrete that you
gonna be shooting I got a question
alright is this game past crackdown or
is this pay $60 crackdown yo on a real
answer your question yes Greenberg in
the corner with a gun on let me ask you
a question
yo keep acting like crackdown was always
this beautiful girl y'all keep acting
like that game was always a plus top
flight game it would never was it was
always a lady with something now it's
associated with game past it was never
on its own it never had feet by itself
it always had some sneakers on to help
it move it always had halo right it
always did it was never take them off
eventually not to Train right but y'all
made this game into something that it's
not
y'all keep talking like it's an a.1
triple-a title it's not even know why
this game is amazing but I am put up
that front like please you do read for
alert for all wrapping the breath cover
says it here please let me talk about
because I have to leave here in about
ten I am not condoning people giving
this game of four or five I think a six
or seven is fair I'm leaning more
towards seven but at the end of the day
I am NOT against people talking this
because it didn't evolve from a
crackdown franchise cuz it didn't but
I'm not going to dock it because it
plays like right down at the end of the
day look at look at franchises that did
change stuff up drastically to try to
bring in a new audience
that didn't really look at their core
audience that like the old crack down
look at halo people love halo 5 it
reviewed well but the actual die-hard
Halo fans are like this they like halo
mm-hmm dear same thing people say this
don't feel like gears
well people said that gears for it felt
too much like gears they didn't try to
reinvent themselves like each game each
game iterated on itself a little bit
these gamers are fickle and a full of
crap yeah they are these dudes are not
playing on the 4k television King is
right because the fact that there's no
excuse not to have 1400 right now hey
everyone's still playing all that 1080p
video after the Walmart go ahead $200
for KTC alright they can trade they
could trade in that TV at 20 bucks and
still get 10% off that's right and then
you could play the hot fire like me well
I'm a I'm gonna tell you the dad at 4k
30 frames per second HDR looks nice but
that's still in the bushes you played on
that PC running out thank you you need
to play a game at 16 I don't know why
they didn't give you the option for a
1080 60 on that game that game is all
about the locomotion and that framerate
is still not great on that X it look
pretty [ __ ] the arts fantastic but play
it on that PC I want the world to know
right now right when we at PAX and all
of us got our laptops our high-power
laptops and I xbox controllers what game
we gonna be playing and y'all gonna look
cause we're gonna had a camera and y'all
gonna see us all playing crack now the
others say oh no I'm not
all right we got a special guest for
this topic all Lord rap of the basement
radio podcast
Enrique are you there sir I am here I
heard I heard dialogues name 80 people
in here like we have a flood today
Lord breath there's been a lot of talk
about crackdown as much as people saying
hot fire so on Cobra what's your
experience with the crackdown game in
just the aftermath of the launch where
you at with this whole situation all
right
so I'm never gonna disparage anyone for
liking this game because if you like
that's great yeah that's a conversation
like that's into some [ __ ] I don't
want you want to think that I'm because
I think what happens a lot of times what
if a reviewer again I see this a lot
like like Ryan McAfee to come out and
explain to people look if we say game is
mediocre it's okay like it doesn't mean
that you're not gonna like it or that
you can't like it and I feel like a lot
of times people get so wrapped up into a
score and what numerical value the game
got and it's like no no one's saying
that if it game scores bad that you
can't like it a lot
I love Rhys rifles will actually want my
finger Xbox exclusive games a great
story for history fans yeah and I love
Roman history I'm on gladiator Roman
give me anything in a Roman setting I am
buying it like that's know and that's
about it you know and so you know I
think that a lot of times people get so
wrapped up and it's like no one's saying
that you can't enjoy this but I what I
will say is I and I got a review code of
the game from from Microsoft and you
know big shout to Aaron because he
hooked me up and I really appreciate it
so I got I got the plate and yeah like I
hear everyone say oh you know it's crock
down what do you expect I'm like yeah
okay it is crackdown but this is
crackdown the crackdown that I
experienced in 2007 worked back in 2007
I just don't feel like it works well in
2019
of the game went through right it's like
I said look you can you can dock it for
not evolving for not evolving to that mm
you know you know the New Age of gamers
but I feel like people are docking it
for it not evolving and it's claim like
crackdown people expected a different
experience like idea of the day no I'm
having I'm having a blast playing this
game it is there's no way that you can't
objectively look at this game and give
it a 4 out of 10
no when I think three and four out of
ten I think broken game well I think
five is why - low - six six six is kind
of iffy but seven definitely I would say
a 7.5 because the game what it does well
it does well yes it didn't evolve it's
funny if you read some of these reviews
people like you I had a blast you know
they literally say in there I had in a
joy I enjoyed playing the game and
they're like 500 i G and I can't explain
it for them a 5 is a mediocre game and
it's like this Duty 8 out of 10 every
year okay but but that's but that's you
okay you okay that's European you may
not agree with them and that's fine we
don't have to agree with the scores but
you know but they did come out and say
look you know five is a mediocre game
for us it doesn't mean you can't like it
it doesn't mean that we have a game
where the fire we're not talking about
jump for it's talking about crackdown
like we got it like in the community we
got to stop like oh but without game it
doesn't move the conversation anywhere
my point is this like like we and I
think gamers need to understand so like
we all enjoy things that are that are
that are average or mediocre we do it in
every aspect of our life how many of us
go to McDonald's and get a Big Mac and
like right now would you would you say a
Big Mac is the premier meal
and I you're not going to go after you
oh yeah bloody you go after Brett well
gay Bradford but a Big Mac is mediocre
but it's okay you enjoyed it you still
liked it but you're not gonna say that a
Big Mac coming from Shake Shack is hot
fire you know it's but it's okay and so
with crackdown like might when I was
playing it yeah I had fun with it but I
wall like after like two hours of
playing like you know I can't do this
anymore it's too repetitive
it just it's not as good as other things
that I've experienced more recently in
the same genre for crackdown yeah it's
it's crackdown but you know me
personally my pit I would have loved to
see the game evolve a little bit I
understand I had divine issues you know
I felt like with Terry Crews they kind
of missed an opportunity too late is he
up yeah like with Terry Crews comes in
and he's like and I'm height I'm a high
he's me like a coach I'm ready like I'm
ready to go out and play the Super Bowl
yeah opportunity to go from mediocre
average to great because you see the
foundation there and you see the
potential that this thing could even be
more again not that the core game is bad
it just hasn't evolved right it's in
Kassadin like they keep treating it like
this it came out as a b-tier game right
but when you look at what do they lack
in right what is Microsoft really
lacking in right a third person
character action game with which Sony
thrives on they have the framework here
to make what is ostensibly a great
superhero game and they did not do that
do you think it's our problem and not
theirs like the expectations that is
laid upon the game like you said it came
out as a b-tier title right right and
it's not living up to its be tier name
oh absolutely in full fourth is living
up to it but but is why does it have to
be there yeah why does it have to be
that point when Phil Spencer says it's
cracked down I'm like okay you act like
you don't own crack that loot you you
act like you're not the
ones that can change that narrative
right and it feels like you don't want
to change it like you know when God of
War came out right um I hated the fact
that it switched over to what it did
love the originals I love that the field
of the button-mashing
the simplicity of you know just the
mindless fun of it I love that yeah that
the sky I just I just love the game when
I got the new oh god what everybody's
raving over it
but they didn't understand my
frustration with it I hated the combat
right but I love this crackdown because
I love the crack now for what it is
now they gave me the extra boost button
because it feels like what's that of the
game from Microsoft with the girl in
Rico like Greek or actually was probably
one of the few people I felt like I'm
like one of the only people in the earth
of b-tree cool this is what I'm saying
we got to a point where the expectations
for the game they were acting like this
game was supposed to be gay was my issue
with it is this community went from you
know waiting for review scores to
putting that [ __ ] on the calendar
because they want to talk [ __ ] about it
I never validate Hwanhee a game to fail
right who are looking at crackdown as an
opportunity yeah he was like why do you
make a crackdown videos like cuz I'm not
gonna cash in on that like yeah at the
end of the day like everyone and
everyone's mob was talking about it on
Twitter
let's get bloody it cuz he ain't get
chance to talk yeah and I'm glad Brett
brought up all this talk about about the
review scores and everything and I got
issues with that right because people
are using this as gospel
no Metacritic open critic all that
aggregate score [ __ ] question sorry
sorry
the aggregate scoring systems right now
are broken in every aspect because of
the fact that here's the thing right
they weight the scores based on certain
keywords that are written in the article
as well as the scores themselves as well
as the number of reviews if you look at
crack don't crack down three scores
right now you're looking at maybe 50 to
60 right so 50 to 60 people's opinions
breaking it down using certain keywords
that the websites use to help rate the
score and then averaging it so 60
people's words is what's giving it the
score it is right why my issue with the
reviews score and how Metacritic an open
credit go on is you have these people
that will literally give a game an 8 out
of 10 that's a broken mess that didn't
function at all it's something like
cracked on that functions well that's
fun but let me add that fun remember
something with reviews these things
exist in a spectrum way of what what
parts may be broken in a game may not
take away from the overall enjoyment of
the game blood-borne has long the job
you didn't take away from the fact but
and but yet you look at you look at
blood board and that is rated 9 and 10
across the board and one example because
I've heard people say oh well you know
like with reek or recore got doc for
loading times I literally heard someone
say oh well you know how come they
didn't dark blood-borne for having you
know long low times and they docked
recore well yeah think about what you
got to think about what blood boards
loading versus what recore is I mean
these things it's not a one-to-one
comparison these things and parts and
pieces of a game all exist in a spectrum
it's never always one-to-one it is at
times but it always it isn't you know it
always isn't a one on one thing so you
can't sit there and be like oh well
so-and-so didn't dock them because you
know the the loading time was longer
than them vote more and they said oh the
loading time was okay with blood-borne
like I heard someone say you know how
come Shadow the Colossus got like a nine
and it plays like shadow Colossus well
shadow Colossus wasn't chatting the
classes too it was it was a remake
remaster of the original man
and actually they improved in some of
the gameplay mechanics
well don't usually well don't say that
because they they improved on what they
did with Gears of War Ultimate Edition
was that uh they docked that that one
scored in the baby my whole generation
and let's not act like in Brad knows and
what was the original here's the world
like a nine from more than ten points
off the same game and shadow costs came
out first and they wasn't improvement
over the original if you play the if you
play the original you played the title
now that what place today really feels
like what the developer had envisioned
for that game and when shadow the
Colossus came out it was it was a game
that was beyond its time like it was
beyond what was capable of the ps2 which
one of the reasons why I got so praised
on the PlayStation 2 when he came out
the ps4 and I went back and played I'm
like this is what they wanted this game
to be like it played much better than
the original yeah but I'm just saying
when it comes down to it is that people
are looking at these scores as as the
end-all be-all when that's not what's
that when that's not what these are
meant to do because as I said the way
that the aggregate scoring algorithm
works it does not work in favor for for
games that have low or even movies and
I'll go specifically the movies you look
at Rotten Tomatoes you look at IMDB all
that you look at a movie like look at
Schindler's List look at the color
purple look at sight Anik look at Gone
with the Wind classic films literally
legendary and all the rights has
thousands upon thousands of reviews you
think that these would be the end-all
be-all movies the greatest of all time
have perfect scores right no you look at
them they're rated either in the high
80s or 8.9 to you know nine point one
and that's from having thousands of
reviews done by multiple people across
multiple generations you want to know
you want to know what has some of the
high scores mmm there's literally one
movie I could tell you right now that
has a hundred on Rotten Tomatoes
Paddington - how many reviews does it
have and and that look that has
67 reviews and I know this because me
and my some of my co-workers got talking
about this you look at you look at the
best way yeah Paddington to has a
hundred percent score because the fact
that has very few reviews in the people
who went to go see that film enjoy that
film they didn't critique it like some
of the critics who looked at classic
films that's why these review scores are
not the end-all be-all go with
everything else be all but that were
bothers me is that once you have that
piling on mentality that sort of mob
mentality when it comes to low review
scores and what I feel to be unfair low
unfairly low review scores in certain
instances what happens is that just that
drives a narrative for everybody like
that yeah if you're if you don't have
that game yet right and you're
interested in it and you're just banking
on what that Moore says that's it you're
not playing it right so that's what I
mean by that like I could care less
about review scores I'm gonna play a
game whether it's a bet exactly you're
taking the word of 60 people's opinions
over the opinion of thousands of others
who actually play in the game and
telling you know it's actually fun it's
not what they're saying but you're gonna
believe the few people and that's where
the issue with it's like these are the
same outlets that gave dying light to
score it did so yeah and and that's why
that's why I'm saying that we have given
too much power to the media and these
aggregate scores because of that fact
because if I would people don't
understand that system that's why it
really is a key factor people need to
determine what is fun for them that's
what and go and play and play the room
okay already know I feel like people
already know what's fun for them like I
think gaming for 37 years like I if I go
to review I'm not looking at the score
I'm reviewing at the body award with
people don't simplify I hear what you
say and I actually agree 1,000% with you
that's where I'm at like to me those
scores and a metric stuff to me that's
just a framework right yeah me an idea
of certain mechanics or any things and
then I also got to take into effect is
the person a fan of the series or the
genre because sometimes people will
review something and they don't give in
so what's going on you know I get that
point but the other part too is just
that like
at the end of the day you know I'm
saying you've got to make that call for
yourself you don't say exactly no man
should have that power no media outlets
have that power where if they put a
school on a game and you love that you
will feel that much and what's funny
what is one of the issues I have is you
know I don't think it's like I said in
the stream these games are going to get
reviewed regardless who reviews them
it could be Bob from accounting that
that they were you know he reviewed
Kingdom Hearts didn't know anything
about the game didn't know the story
didn't know any of them he reviews it
which you know it's his it's his
objective opinion he came in there with
his objective opinion said on yeah he
said be very thorough about it I'm new
to the franchise I've never played it
but his his opinion in his score he
gives it he's gonna just Metacritic
score yeah that's the issue I had
because you had these people putting
these people reviewing these games and
it's the whole system's fault all right
hold on wait I'd say I gotta cut you
right now because we have the Lord of
PlayStation didn't only royalty we have
the man that has been on the crackdown
Street with the shotgun no down xbox is
all over the road oh yeah what's up
everybody my brother's been up to good
good list I'm sure you've been having
such a great time no I'm sure you know
it's all sunny in Charlotte so you
looking outside that champagne drinking
that champagne on that Twitter he's
gonna give you what you think he's gonna
give you an exact listen they listen to
daily I'm telling you okay so okay so
you know Xbox community y'all caught me
at a at a great time three weeks
straight I've been going
Twitter gelatin meditating cleanse and
everything and it's kind of it's
mellowed me out so y'all have a seat st.
I've been seeing me going savage as much
yeah it is much so let me tell you my
new drug mod thoughts on Craig down
right this is not the new enlightened
Kratos you know opinion hmm so I've been
saying this for a long time for years
that I think people have put too much
stock in crackdown itself because the
previous games were never as huge as
people would like them to be they were
okay games you know they were it was a
middle down the road game but it was
never supposed to be up there with halo
gears and fours and I don't even know
why the Microsoft executives say that
you look at if they had if Sony had so
it felt the same way about uncharted 1
hmm where would we be listen this is the
third game in that series they tried it
the first time right it was only it was
okay I mean they they tried it on the
follow-up it was don't expect crackdown
3 to be the savior of this generation
all right let me let me let me let me
double in cuz I hear what solve is going
I don't wanna I know where you're going
and I know what King is going with that
but the question becomes are we as all
as the Xbox company are they allowed to
not demand a better sequel are they not
allowed to say hey we want progression
because the consensus seems to be that
this is more of the same but just like
an oppressed version and they're not a
lot of new regime it's not no denying
what you're saying and I mean I really
would have had like cradles to finish
this point Bob because he's gonna say
exactly what I've been saying but I
wanted to come from a Sony dude because
I know when he picked up the game here
same expectations I did because we had
him so shows please so this this game
was never going to again be the savior
of this generation but I'll tell you
this right we gave this game so much
weight was the cloud power talk the
detective this was supposed to be the
tech the the leading tech thing that
pulls us into the next generation on and
on and on but here's the thing right so
many other people have tried different
things dealing with the cloud and no one
else has tried to do this but Microsoft
and whether or not you like it or not
they talked about to see if these cloud
with the with the water and stuff like
that I don't know I always thought it
was far-fetched but crackdown if you
like the first to being you like part
three this was I think people put too
much state and I think feel ultimately I
would say it is and I'm just gonna be
honest when they started counseling
scale bone in that and all of those
games previously in line his Studios
this would have been a game that feel
would have tossed in there to this was
another game but he had to save
something because grape tree tag yeah
that those pictures became really short
that banner became really short so they
had to keep something right okay
personal legends nobody's respecting a
playstation dude that constant I mean
this is the this is the thing right
all these PlayStation dudes are they if
they didn't play the game whatever they
have some negative to say I knew for a
fact that he wasn't gonna have anything
negative to say about it and he gives a
lot of praise to Xbox stuff that people
don't give him credit for
mmm-hmm but he states the facts when it
comes to some of these PlayStation games
is really top to any of us thought we
or expect to crack down to be the savior
of anything my thing is just evolution
you have em plate if you look at how
spite think about it think about
spider-man last year right all of the
abilities in spider-man had all the
stuff you can unlock now imagine that
sort of same sort of template for a
crackdown game or games of that ilk that
have come since then and the thing about
it with me is that it's row four okay it
cracked down and and what was what was
the ancestor to that which one which
game started all of that open world
crazy explosive stuff so it's a
reasonable expectation for them to take
to try to take the forefront and evolve
in the formula but other things have
done it before that right hoping your
construction even before that the same
pro games right mom prototype even
intance of mayhem and the more stuff
with it and I'm like okay why you keep
treating it like this game has to stay
famous body can't rise above it station
because if you think about it you know
that's done with multiple industries
people to this day still complain
they're sprinting inhaler yeah they want
it back to the old formula that you
can't sprint you can't aim downsides no
one truly wants a franchise to evolve
into involves let me jump in because
everybody's making fantastic points like
for the record I am NOT a crack down man
right I've never understood the appeal
to the game to be honest it was always
known to me as the packing game that you
can use as yes it's crap it's history so
I didn't even try the original game
because I just wanted that Halo beta
yeah but you know get to crack down you
know look I have fun playing a multi
player on a simplistic level few laughs
you know I didn't like I couldn't play
the friends but everything about the
core gameplay loop I'm which solve it
just is so antiquated you're not I'm
saying but if you're a fan of crackdown
I get it like I totally understand why
they may love it I'm not knocking anyone
net you know it likes it but and I'm
with bloody on this like crackdown fit
don't let no another man or media not
your enjoyment of the game like if you
having fun do what you do I'm a destiny
God built for the smoke
so exactly every Lord on a round table
knows does it mean a soft everyone here
III 2017 we saw it adjoint behind closed
doors yeah we all said like up racetrack
down man that's to delegate always don't
animations that are on the way it hits
floor hit the movement I just felt that
they needed to do that so now we got the
lack of the Xbox party I'm on launch
unable to use certain saves in the coop
very minimalistic features and my fit
you know listen I'm with Kratos this
shows me failure Microsoft when at this
game out the door at all costs
regardless of the complexity to the
cloud tech then it was not going to be
no further delays with this game post
and and there's no denying that aspect
you got people fail to also remembers
that this game had went through two
almost three different studios as well
as it's the last remnants of the
previous regime they needed to clear out
everything that was from the past
exactly so they did my opinion they
gonna eat the negative press you own it
let it hibernate in game pass they can
get a better patch do whatever you're
gonna do
films pretty much like we're gonna take
the elephant take it now here's the
thing though here's the thing we feel
with them at mantra right
he should have took all his sales
upfront when he was canceling when a
council scalebound and all this stuff go
ahead and get it wait you know I wonder
we always forget you know there's a lot
of investments and investors and you
know stock like canceling all those game
it was it would have dropped their sake
I mean listen the worst thing that
happened back being right they lost all
the studios they not lost but they kind
of got rid of they they chopped a bunch
of stuff right line here went on okay we
got council scalebound and in the rest
the rest we don't have to repeat you
know repeat all the stuff that happened
at that time go ahead and get that out
the way so you don't have to spin the
next four years
dragging this mess on now people people
are continuously say well this is this
is this was the the old regime this was
done IDI and mom
they had to learn our say safeiy is one
of those things that if you keep giving
your community let's be real this
generation has been at Ellen's far as
first party right yeah so then it's been
bearing the cupboard is bare right so if
you cancel the scalebound
right you can sue all these get you're
creating such negative energy you have
to give them something so am i film made
a decision say look this is not for
Meyer this is the Dom natural error
we're going to finish this thing and you
know say it's like you know a street
child that he's inherited from this
point on he's like the next generation
is my vision my studio all the things
that I'm gonna do so to me that's when I
truly hold his feet to the fire
regarding the problem listen here's the
problem with that though and I want to
agree with you but I before it's a
different mindset you know this is 2019
right the last two to three years in the
generation that's when these consoles
should have been hitting their stride
with knocking all the gangs out of the
park right now on the other camp it
seems like Nintendo and Sony can't lose
absolutely it seems like every game they
drop even days going coming even if
you're not interested in it you know
without a doubt that game is gonna be at
least a 78 to a mid 80 you don't even
like those type of games you know it's
gonna be of a certain quality and that
leads me to
whitfill in the executive team where is
the quality control right they stay over
these games they know what shake is
going everyone know and you can show
that and they can't sort so many games
with this narrative they feel I'm not
that's the one thing we miss crackdown
I'm glad he stuck with it I'm glad he
pushed it out the door you know why
because hot fire for me
lazy but he put it out the ball game
past said it's available you know who's
up like this like do you guys think that
would make a they would make a sequel to
this no no for then you will hear beat
the story no I was gonna I can almost
guarantee there's gonna be a crackdown
for ya know I was gonna agree with you
here's the reason because as well they
own the IP is that once they have a
dedicated studio for this game that's
what that's what I'm here I bet the
reason it wasn't cancelled because they
do have more crackdowns planned but they
had to get this one because they took it
away from ruffian and then they gate
they forced the sumo to kind of pick up
what they had with the assets and sumo
how to start over Sumer how to start
over but they kept some of the assets
but I really don't care about the
problems no no no no no no but what I'm
saying is that the addict is right there
they're gonna put more into it but
that's why it that's why it's a lot of
people are hating on it but also
respected that's the reason that they
never cancelled this game that they made
sure it came out regardless what
happened it's cuz they're ending in this
game you know I'm not gonna spoil
anything of this game I feel like the
white they ended it though the amount of
attack that they were getting to it the
whole dead cycle they wouldn't have made
the ending they would have would have if
they weren't gonna make here that's it
opened here's the thing right they
didn't just leave it open they they
didn't even leave the hallway but you
walked out was like there's like it's
not even a cliffhanger it's it's like
what hey hope there is not a crackdown
for and I'm gonna tell you how would you
say that my excuse is very logical for
this reason we gave we gave you three
tries right we gave you three tries
three generations
narration are you now listen I do not
want any any I'm
I'm choosing my words I'm vegan so I'm
processing I do not want any of the
baggage that came from this children Joe
Biden no I get it
you realize I don't I don't want Xbox to
be the underdog forever next generation
I want them to come out with nothing but
brand new IPs and yes they can come out
with the halo gives in Forza but I don't
want that to be the bread and butter
again I want them to think about how
many brand new IPS that Sony gave you
this particular generation that wasn't
from last a bunch of brand new IPs that
we know we're getting sequels to I want
that for Microsoft I don't want to them
I don't want to crack they're liable to
come out and we were still one we're
still shaking her head why can't we have
both I do it because never that game but
the part that was in 82 so we say 80
Tuesday's listen garbage' always saying
we can't have both generation to crack
down come in that doesn't matter
are we living in 82 I personally believe
the it was critically Dre is living in
the glory days of yesteryear we're not
we have ours why only two more days like
I'm actually like that stuff that you
talking about like I heard but me
personally fun I had with spider-man I'm
having the same amount of fun with crack
now and let me tell you why mm-hmm
I can you know when Annie was like I'm
not getting those book bags I got every
last look back which is like I think it
like this is the fun part this is that
part where I was going to every park
beating up people they said it was
repetitive they did like a lot of people
got a lot of negative stuff let's fight
him in the hell with them that was my
game of the year this joint I'm under
inside bushes inside corners getting
orbs jumping to the highest I'm doing so
much crazy stuff with being a superhero
which is the game allows me to be I'm
having so much fun now people are
starting to use this stuff as gospel
this Metacritic this garbage that people
are oh it got a 67 I'm not gonna check
it out how about that guy had a bias
going in how do you not know if that
game is not a shoot but if you've got
game pass reason you can't check it out
and if you don't we've always used
Metacritic as a census of what the
masses in the editorial room think of
again yes you can have a game to come
out and be a twenty Metacritic and still
love it
thus the original state of decay I love
that game and it didn't knock the socks
off for everybody now is also an arcade
game
wait did you even play have you played
the third one yet I got it yes I got it
have you played it I didn't ask you can
dance around this question yeah I just
said fifteen minutes so I got you guys
here's the thing right all right me
going in right I'm not I think that's
the cutscene in about three minutes a
game play God you want to give a game
why I'm gonna give his fair share I just
haven't really been gaming a lot period
oh you know I see your explain myself
about what I was doing
or so y'all probably really true we sold
what once once I'm done with doing my
thing then I'm back on my gaming grind
or whatever so I'm gonna get down to it
that's just say that I'm not gonna play
it I'm just at that point now where this
game was never gonna be with most people
most people thought it was have fun with
the game you can be ecstatic about it
you can thoroughly enjoy but at the same
time this was not the game to be holding
on your shoulders in anticipation of
waiting I think the next game that you
can can hold on your shoulders is gonna
be yours far because that will give you
a consistent mid to high 80s and but
again how do we get to the point where
we can set gears to the side because we
know that that's going to always give us
something good
halo I always give us something good for
us always gonna give us some good what
is the next few games that's gonna allow
us to attach to that team remember they
said that crackdown was they wanted that
game up there with the halo games and
that's the reason I feel like they
didn't cancel it because they got plans
at the franchise with this game as they
always out sourced it but they're not
doing that anymore the blind studios are
making sure everything's and out yeah
uses oh why these games come out came
out right nobody had excuses on why this
game didn't get a high Metacritic right
nobody nobody on it on the Sony stuff
from what I'm seeing there shouldn't
when their games don't do what they
should do there's never excuse oh this
is because of this orange because of
that is just I guess I don't much about
it there's another example there's
another game out here that's going to be
highly rated that you know when you have
a bunch of big hitters you can have duds
and nobody care but when you have a
bunch of duds and a handful of heavy
hitters
it looks spooky and this is why Xbox for
this generation is this is why their
mindset is is there this is what
change the way they do in things we
thought the cloud was gonna be this
we're not gonna see here and act like
Microsoft's not taking precautions to
fix this issue I'm tired of this persona
that people be acting like no one's
trying to hold on we gotta get press
like y'all been gored his man hasn't
talked yet Brad can you get in here
please
thank you yes I just want to say
something about the perception of and
you guys have heard me talk about media
bias and things in incognito we talked
on DM earlier today that conversation we
hear every couple yeah they let the man
finish man I mean my my concern is every
time there's a game that comes out from
Microsoft first party that doesn't score
well everyone blames the media and I
said this on crossfire let's look at and
I have been Xbox day one I mean day one
launch oh gee Xbox I was a beta tester I
have a lot of love for the Xbox but I'm
concerned by some of the thinking in the
mindset of the community that I feel is
detrimental in the sense that you know
what it's not the media that's making
the games it's Microsoft's and let's not
lose sight of that you know yeah I -
that your lack of minority speak for the
majority no but problem when you bring
these up you let the small portion to
people but that's the problem though the
cake came out garnet whatever you did
not say did I not say in the condition
it was a dessert people hear those
voices it's this prominent thing and I
see it a lot on the time on my timeline
and it's people all Ryan doesn't get it
rinds bias that the me in the media hate
Xbox you know there's you know yet kids
move out the second there's a hit there
you know that he believes that Kotaku
and other kids
whose opinion speak for everyone but but
you know what's the way you're acting
like the whole community has there's a
lot of people people you name it right
now that says stuff like it's moved it
yes absolutely I see it all the time
name me five main meaning Oh mainly
names we know people talking about these
agree with him and now we got people
comparing Xbox whoa Jim Crow that's
crime easy it's well here's the thing
what what we gotta talk I want to get to
you breath is that so your okra feel I
just want to get your point your overall
feeling is that the Xbox community is
making excuses for the title and blaming
media buys as to as to why it's going
bad like what is your feeling about the
crackdown aftermath that's what I do
think that yeah like I said III think if
you have fun with the game the other day
that's all that matters fact you know
and and you shouldn't let anyone if
someone doesn't agree with you know you
having like the media if they give it a
six they're not telling you you can't
have fun who cares
facts it's a different opinions at the
end of the day but it's not because the
media's buys when they hate Xbox you
know that's that's that's nonsense you
know it's just a difference of opinions
anymore focus and all those they focus
way too much on that and then the other
part the part that worries me is that
then there's the issue of accountability
right you know like you got we have to
hold these companies accountable to and
then I'm up in arms when EA does crazy
stuff with microtransactions you know
there has to be that same accountability
for everything I think and I feel like
at times it's just not I feel like
there's a lot of deflection that goes on
I don't see this you're talking about I
see well all the time say let me say
something here we wrap I completely
agree with you about accountability but
also and I'm gonna say this in two parts
because
to agree with you and disagree with you
and they took accountability they know
that they took accountability after
everything that they had canceled before
because the fact that they were getting
rid of things that were well out of
their hands we saw how the development
was going for for fable legends a lot of
people weren't feeling it a lot of the
money that was put into and a lot of
people who purchase that who were going
through the beta they refunded
everyone's money right I saw people who
were buying the stuff out that because
the fact that fable legends wasn't
living up to what they wanted we saw the
the investment that they put behind
scalebound and why they canceled that
and they they took accountability for
that because they wash your hands of it
because we saw kind of and heard a lot
of the horror stories on the development
side of that on what was going on with
platinum but we're not going to talk
about that we just know that's why they
kind of wash that why they kept crack
down and pulled it away from ruffian and
then gave it to sumo digital is because
the fact that sumo digital one of their
their second party developers they're
working with them trying to help bring
them up like they've done with undead
labs like we're seeing with studio mvhr
and other things they knew that the game
was going to be issues right so they
were taking accountability by putting it
with one of their second parties letting
them work on it given them the time to
do what they could with it with the game
so they did take accountability in the
aspect that they knew it wasn't gonna be
this big hitter but they want it to be
and that's why we're definitely gonna
still potentially see more what the
series come later but the thing is that
they have to have that dedicated studio
for like we're seeing with everything
else we have the dedicated halo we had
the dedicated gears we have a dedicated
Forza like they're building and they're
letting other studios experiment or if
they want to do something different
they're letting them do that but what
they need to do is they are trying to
set up a dedicated studio for this or a
dedicated team and I think that's where
the accountability is gonna come forward
they knew it wasn't gonna be a big
hitter
before you get jumping creds I know
where you gonna go I think I know you
but what I want to ask bloody is what do
you say to the general consensus that
you know they look at the Xbox brand and
software and say hey this generation has
been a bunch of overall 60 titles a lot
of mediocrity and that Xbox fans the
consensus is that you know we are making
excuses that you know we should demand
better and that whenever there is a
mediocre game that drops that there's
always a but and what if kind of thing
like what
you say to that group of gamers that
says that about me because if I say to
them that the the generation has been a
good generations not great generation I
won't I won't deny that fact there's no
there's no deflecting that but
everything that that we've gotten has
set basis for what a lot of people are
getting out now why everyone on the Sony
camp don't and and love to them hyped up
and got excited for spider-man that's
great you know what what they did with
that game is great
well the precedent for that game and the
groundwork for that game all came from
sunset overdrive on what what they did
over here first the movement the
traversal that kind of world that came
from from their first yeah look at what
now remedy is doing with control that
was set with the groundwork from Alan
Wake and wanna break OH
all that stuff is getting ground work
because of the work that has been done
with these studios yes they may not have
been great games before but they're
they're working towards even greater
games next whether there are multi plats
whether exclusive whatever it's all
setting the groundwork and now we're
gonna to see really what not just the
second third parties are doing we're
gonna see how much better the first
parties are gonna do there definitely
has that potential and they're showing
it now slowly over time all right let me
get Kratos so don't get King and we got
to move on from crackdown so cradles I
want you get you your final thoughts on
it okay my final thoughts on this
breakup I gotta go you guys been a
pleasure thanks thank Kratos and Pratt
for coming on everyone definitely last
time I checked there's 88 people and I
appreciate everyone will come through
like button we don't like alert few
doubt the like cradles okay but back
back back to what you were just saying
that is there is a consistence
generation that in we can't deny that
this generation was defined by a bunch
of 60s 60s rated games and this is why
when I'm doing what I grow on Twitter I
say that's the Xbox template the sixty
template right if Microsoft in The
Dropper game
you know I don't care what a damn soul
says about this game I don't really care
it's hot it's a bunch of people that is
running lemon all these dudes is running
behind with me holding this flag up
because I'm so happy that this game was
not cancelled yeah I so scalebound yeah
so problems with it I wish that game was
in canceled but a lot of stuff had to
die from that error
don't front like stuff was going on wall
over there that wasn't done right and
this man is coming and cleaning up all
the crap that's in the basement so you
have a solid foundation studios he's
doing this so that they talk about that
they they excel into mediocrity they're
looking to us mediocrity has to go that
is not to go they're looking at the
leaders right now and it's saying that's
the goal and to exceed that so Sony is
leading right now can't take that away
from them they make good choices and
they are definitely in the forefront
right now Nintendo Sony always Microsoft
next generation is putting itself in
position to win this man put this game
out from from another dual situation
like Chimera said the redheaded
stepchild in the corner man the
redheaded stepchild needed this moment
to shine whether you like him or not he
out here and what addict says is true my
heart is so open for the next crackdown
hopefully they do what sovereign says
and they date they elevate it to another
level they do something I don't care as
long as Phil gets his fair shake
this man has took away the power
narrative this man has taken away the
y'all don't even do HD 4k this man has
sit down foundations and it's moving
forward let's not act like this man has
not taken it from the doldrums of that
the 720p crap it's moving forward may
not be up to your standards right now
but when we look at the next generation
y'all can say Phil did that because this
is why they're where they're at okay
look at the streaming foundations that
they're doing with X cloud and how they
say that they want it on every device
and look at look at the fact of they
want to put it on mobile devices how are
you gonna play this game on mobile
device you want a controller right what
did the Xbox controllers have now
built-in Bluetooth so you connect those
devices to play those new exactly
exactly all that that foundation in the
meantime and it means how what is going
on Sony has its biggest bangers coming
continue to strive and DNS not including
the sequels and it's also not including
but all the new stuff that they can work
in my life known what sequel is the only
sequel that we know about right now is
neo to cold all right y'all literally
transition perfectly for Luis he's like
yeah let's get more sauce we have some
discussions the Sony hey what is it
Shawn Layden drop me a lot of stuff
going on Sony so we can literally bring
this in okay so this top my topic is
really just talking about Shawn lady's
interview with Game Informer and added
to that actually his his dice
presentation yeah and bass and the
recent sort of reshuffling of executives
at Sony and what that means for the
future of the company so let's start
with which song ladies interviewer Game
Informer and his dice presentation first
when I initially was gonna come at this
I was gonna kind of come at this kind of
hard because
I uh this is one thing that I feel with
Sony and I think it happens with
everybody but with Sony just because I
think in terms of innovation in terms of
in they've been known to follow a lot in
terms of actual innovation great games
fantastic first party stuff but in terms
of you know services things of that
nature things of sort of moving where
consoles are going forward I've always
thought they've been fought they
followed um
so initially I was gonna attack that
because I always felt when in this
particular interview when Sean talks
about like the changes they had to make
when when the pressure from fortnight
was on and the cross-play stuff he made
it seem as if you know they had to step
back from this situation that you know
they didn't understand per se and they
had to come up with a proper Sony like
solution for it which is just it's a lot
of mumbo-jumbo for saying we had to just
bend the knee and say look this is the
way things are going we have to change
um and they honestly when I read the
entire interview when I listen to the
die summit stuff it was he he was a lot
more open to where the future of gaming
is going and it didn't feel as much like
he was just sort of spinning it in a
Sony type of way so that said it's
really interesting to me that he he gave
credit to Nintendo he gave credit to
Microsoft for the things that are
happening in the industry that it's it's
creating a narrative for what the future
of consoles is gonna be and it's made it
clear that PlayStation is on that ride
too they they're not necessarily going
to stay where they've been right they're
gonna focus on what's been strong for
them which is first / single-player
narrative driven games right um he said
specifically that they're not going to
be making more more games in that ilk
for set per se they're gonna have less
games and focus on having them be
stronger quality which is it's something
that they've that's their mantra quality
above all else it takes quality above
all else and respect that but what's
interesting is that he made a specific
statement in his interview with game
before saying I don't want to put too
hard a point
this but we're looking and I don't want
to do it because I might piss some
people off that I work with but we're
looking at a post consul future where
where you play means a lot less than
what you're playing and that's what
we're looking to focus on and I caught
that too I caught that and it's kind of
it's it's cool that they're finally on
this bandwagon same wavelength it's just
interesting to me and and and the
changes that they've made in terms of in
the executive swaps indicate that
they're all in on that right right when
you look at swap between John Code era
and and Jim Ryun code era is not gonna
go back to what he initially did was
focusing on the services and focusing on
on on on all the guts and underlying
stuff of the PlayStation Network which
is that's what his strength is so he's
gonna go back to that and Jim Ryan is
gonna go back to being that face
executive right and not necessarily
worry so much about games but worry
about the strength of the business
moving forward and what that means and I
think that's a perfect position for him
as well so these movements show that
they are absolutely 100% on board with
that and I'm glad we have cradles here
today because me too I want to know I
want to know what a PlayStation guy
mm-hmm about this because they're
essentially saying in a sense like monta
we give up we have to we have to get up
we have to get on this train too and we
have to do it in a PlayStation way and
he made it clear that they're still
gonna be focusing on what makes them
strong but that they have to follow suit
with what Microsoft is essentially doing
and what place and what Nintendo is kind
of doing as well okay let's go let's go
cradles alright so let me tell you this
a lot of people a lot of people think
that Sony is is following in Microsoft
footsteps and what they're trying to do
with this the whole streaming and stuff
like that now I just want to bring you
back to this point last generation they
were first sony has PlayStation now man
am i right but they were I mean am I
wrong am i right now yeah yes yes they
bought the the Gakkai and they did the
whole streaming thing first so let's not
make it seem like they just
sideline Sony has always invested in
doing things you just don't hear because
it's not at the forefront you know again
their motto games first everything else
second in and that's been successful for
them right now I give it I give props to
Microsoft could they do let you in on a
lot of stuff that they're doing with the
clouds and every server 'z and stuff
they they let you know they're very
transparent with that whereas Sony they
kind of focus on exactly what they're
doing with that particular market now
here's the second thing I can see right
and I applaud it sure the future you
cannot hold up progress at all it's
inevitable it's inevitable that we're
going to be streaming our games in the
future out that I can't say if you're
gonna be ten years from now I can said
it's gonna be twenty thirty fifty it
doesn't matter but at the same time
right you're gonna have fifty wouldn't
really call it fifty streaming services
out there amazon has there's Google
gonna have theirs Apple is working on
there's Microsoft working on there
sony's working on the others and we
already know Nintendo is I don't know
somewhere right so at the end of the day
right if we can no longer talk about you
know if these consoles go away and it's
no long it's no longer about my
processor is a little bit faster yours
mighty flops a little bit faster than
yours what does that bore down to if
today right if Microsoft to this day
right now this generation said it we're
forgoing any hardware and we're just
gonna give you games how would that
change from xboxes circumstances and how
would that change Sony circumstances and
Sony still has those that everyone you
know they still have the install base
right the type of games they have and
Microsoft's do you have the type of
games that they have Nintendo still have
the type of games they have that doesn't
change anything hardware will never
change anything right right because at
the end of the day look at Nintendo they
have the weakest console and yet they're
not getting out the box over and over
it's about the games games games games
games and I think we need to take a
pause in all admit all right there was a
time and I think Microsoft actually did
the interview when they were talking
about um and I need to find that link
and I will send it to you guys but
basically in the start of every
generation it is about power right
that's that gets you ramped up but after
the second year they transitioned and
it's all about the games because you can
no longer
sell someone on power after they have
already bought the console here's more
about the games to sustain it this is
why I mean it is about games games games
so if we go into all streaming feature
right now today today I think the
positions would stay the same
now next generation I'm pretty sure
Microsoft we're gonna have some better
games there's one a weight is what
structure you what you're talking about
yes yes no no listen
Microsoft has infrastructure Sony
currently have the infrastructure but
again they're not there they may not be
as strong as Microsoft because Microsoft
they make their bread and butter with
yeah whereas Tony has other things but
that's not to say that they're gonna be
lagging behind in edia there we just
don't know there but let me ask you this
question and I'm gonna give it back to
Tim Russert panel like what about
remember when Phil kind of came out as a
head on the whole device playing
anywhere thing right and there was a lot
of backlash from the community because
people were saying like oh my god Xbox
traditional consoles are going away and
they're getting out of the business and
all this so what do you say to this now
when you see Shawn Layden saying hey
we're essentially going to be doing the
same thing where Sony's gonna be on
every device and we don't necessarily
care about the platform you play you
know you play on like because we
remember a lot of yeah the Xbox base was
getting attacked listener you can always
look at things from YouTube Twitter ban
our fanboy standpoint right but that
that's to cause a jab at certain
communities ones on the internet right
that's what that is but at the end of
the day we gotta face reality
you know we jab at on YouTube and
Twitter is not necessarily
hundred-percent what's going on behind
the scenes you know a lot of people
don't know that you know Yoshida Shawn
Layden same field and they're really
good friends talking about what we finna
say and
yes you know that makes forget to
entertain me right you think there there
is a certain section of gamer of our
heart or gamer right they gravitated to
Sony this generation because of what
Microsoft was doing immediately
PlayStation was perceived as the
hardcore players console the hardcore
old-school console yes
what do you into that person that really
does believe that and it I don't think
is it's necessarily a super small number
what do you say to that person they then
can't has to deal with with this new
reality right here's not a PlayStation
brand know those people that you're
talking about those were worthy
disenfranchised people that were dissing
they were disgruntled from the Kinect in
the TV talk they wanted their halo gears
and fours and their big bangers that
they got the previous generation they
didn't want to hear about all of this
other stuff you know and so that that
kind of made that 720p it was it was a
it was a combination of things
this generation end up like this just
because of power or just because of one
thing it was a combination you know the
biggest aspect of it that really helped
in the beginning and and there's no way
to deny it is that you're right the
disenfranchised of people who got burned
from the 2013 that was literally that
conference is what killed Xbox off the
gate because all places Sony needed to
do was say hey look we're gonna focus on
games and this is this big focus they
literally just had to say the opposite
of what they did they were able to sweep
it away that that's really what killed
it so the whole generation was literally
just clean up over over time and there's
there's no denying that as Xbox fans we
can't we can't say that say anything but
it has been a hard generation because it
was a lot of cleanup and and that's not
always necessarily bad thing we're
seeing the kind of betterment that's
come out of it but it has been a hey
catch up clean up throughout the gen and
and trying to deny that or downplay that
fact is there's no let me say this real
quick and this is just to add on to you
right to all my ex brethren out there
right here's the thing about it this
generation played out the way it played
out it's time to let it go yeah my
friend listen because of how they messed
up in beginning they have weak weak you
cannot prevent them from taking their
due lumps when you slash generation
remember they came out with you know you
gotta get a second job they came out
they wanted the ps3 won't be hard to
develop for on purpose because we need
like three computers for a game
generation and then and into Sean ladies
credit like he acknowledged that in his
diced in his dice of speech he said yes
he went through the entire all the
generation he said PlayStation 2 any
pause he said that was a moment of what
we've always said a moment of hubris
making him back to bite us like he was
very honest about that and how that
forced them to become what they are
today yes that's what you know sometimes
that's with it and my hope is with
Microsoft that that's what happened
right they we're in the process of
seeing that happen at all those lumps
they took at the beginning was humor as
they told you in the beginning all right
don't worry about the games we're gonna
talk about this TV stuff real quick
hundred dollars we can excel like that a
little bit cheaper and then not to
mention that Donnie deal was not the PR
man because literally when he when
they're saying what it what's always
online what about the offline he's like
well we got a constant for that so 360
is like no you don't say that literally
with Sony K most days right after was
like this is how we trade use game
so what I'm saying Valens credits to
what I was saying is that all Sony had
to do was say the exact opposite of
everything bad that Microsoft said at
the beginning of the gen and it was done
it was done for them to be the good was
this this dead horse has been beaten
slave King it literally being dead for
so long that we actually had to go dig
it back up and then start beating it
again we're gonna talk about exactly
what Shawn was talking about and moving
forward and how this affects that part
we're not gonna talk about the fact that
they're winning in charge now one thing
one thing there was a little bit of some
people perceive as a little bit
disingenuous and what he said is the
cross play stuff and and detailed
because it seems that there amongst
there there is a narrative out there
saying that there's preference to who
they give cross malleability yup arm
there's been some issues with chuckle
fish and their latest game they've
requested on multiple occasions to get
cross play kind of opened up for them
and they've been told no on categorical
hi-rez studios and studios yeah
apparently policy-wise everything is not
necessarily as across the board yet as
they've sort of got a job because cuz
literally that's where the big
discrepancy is because in the interview
you know Shawn Lane in pretty much
states that you know hey if you reach
out your speaking to the developed if
you reach out to your PR your account
person on the Sony side it's as easy as
that is getting the implementation with
the cross but that's all they have to do
is speak to their account manager but
then when we saw the CEO of hi-rez
Studios he deliver his tweet says hey he
acts only at PlayStation it's time to
stop playing favorites and tear down the
cross plane progression wall for
everyone he said we have smite paladins
game and realm royale ready to go when
you are so the fact that tweet went
viral but there seem to be some
disconnect I'm not gonna blatantly say
dudes is lying out here
clearly there's a disconnect so that
part has to get cleaned up because
clearly you know a lot of devs
one-and-half cross-play on the platform
and they're feeling that Sony is playing
favorites with somebody you know some
developers can you remember when when
when before that one before for last 76
game guys are all these different dips
which was on Sony about cross play
across play cross play dance Tony said
okay here's cross play you can have it
now they started moonwalking backwards
oh well we it's gonna take us not it's
not the snap of a finger
like they initially say it and it's like
okay what you work on your product let
me back off both you kratos and you
there kognito is that yes everyone was
begging for or asked for cross way and
there's definitely dead out there who
want to do it but the biggest thing is
that they're blocking cross progression
look at how long it took for them to
open up the beta for fortnight and
that's still still going more free to
play a paywall yeah well we go with that
but the bigger the biggest thing here is
cross progression from being able to
take your stuff across any platform that
you're on and be able to use that that's
the that is something that absolutely
has to be key cross play right now we've
seen that that Microsoft or that Sony
does do favorites right because they
keep their cross play between
PlayStation and they keep it with PC and
we've seen that even some of their own
people and a lot of the the people that
do cross way over there has said that
they want to open up to other consoles
but they can't do the ports because the
fact that they want to do cross play
amongst other things and the biggest one
is final fantasy xiv s director when and
we're not talking the original Final
Fantasy 14 that came out back in the PSO
you know we're talking about realm
rebirth with all the new updates that
they've done on the ps4 and PC the
director says that he wants to put that
on on Xbox and he wants that cross
progression but they can't do that until
Sony opens up cross play and XP and Sony
was completely quiet on that
rashon Layden's entire interview like
that
was the most controversial about
converse no no he got called out on it
but he called out all he damn what these
women they don't know is that she also
is he contradicts himself in his
interview because I'm not talking about
what he said about that during the Dyson
is the interview that came later as he
was talking about what their plans are
for the future especially on them not be
a t3 right so he stated and he started
this right by talking about why back in
1995 that Sony pulled out of CES no
longer want to showed their hardware
there and why they would decide to start
showing off at e3 and the purpose of e3
originally for anyone who doesn't know
III was originally a showcase for
retailers and investors in the gaming
industry yeah yeah well there's still a
lot of people who don't know but that's
where they would go to show off anything
that they had coming off and and
everything to kind of help push stuff
for the for the holiday sales and stuff
like that and then he goes and talks
about how this year they don't want to
show up there that they can have the
media come to them they could do their
own event and stuff like that and do a
bigger and that III is really irrelevant
when they don't have anything to show
but later on when he was stating after
he was asked a question he says well
just because we're not going to be a on
e3 this year doesn't mean we can't come
back next year or why they're going back
to CES it's hard to show off some of
their hardware they're after you know
they start dedicating their TVs and
cameras so if these if these shows are
irrelevant and you don't need them to
show off then why go back to them and
show off there because if you're if
you're going to these shows to show off
that means they have some sort of
relevancy but I think they didn't just
say that obviously initially will be
there
initially the beef that I had with the
interview net and that's what I said I
was gonna go out at heart was because of
that specific of the reasons he gave for
not being at et right and he initially
came he came out with that spin but sort
of like listen III is changing it's not
what it was it doesn't make any sense
and that's yes right any any and he went
there and he said that right but then in
a sense he sort of betrayed that a
little bit later when he said the truth
of the matter is he basically said the
true the matter is we don't got anything
to show we don't have anything that they
don't know about yet
or that we can talk about just yet so it
doesn't make any sense for us to be
there that sort of kind of fixes that
right the whole narrative that it's
changing and it's about look it's been
changing for two or three years I've
been evolving for a long time now this
is it's a gamer centric show now at this
point and it's and if it feels messed up
that your narrative is sort of like well
it doesn't matter so much that we were
there for the gamers and that's how it
feels a little bit right even if they
don't have anything new to show the fact
is gamers are gonna be there they want
to see so many stuff regardless of what
it is you should be there period exactly
let me finish is this reasoning behind
it makes sense and he did actually sort
of elaborate on that he's like look
honestly the fact that matter is we
don't have anything new to give them
fair enough fair enough saw braaap what
did you feel about the Shawn Layden
interview was your and in the statements
in reference cross-brace or definitely
thought you know what I what I thought
was very insightful to get kind of their
perspective on you know first party that
you know focusing on quality and you
know I think that for them it's you know
hey look you know we I think they've
come to realization this this generation
that they're they're up there with like
the likes and intended terms of first
party for me to attend has always been
the pinnacle of first party in terms of
development games I think Tony's right
up there with him now which is crazy I
would never I've never said that about
any any first party studio development
team prior to this generation and I
thought he gave some really good insight
that I really liked his topics and
talking about VR yes I like that too
yeah so there's been there's been some
controversy about VR you know is it is
it a fad is it here to stay you know and
and and you know they they said hey look
you know what you don't get to you know
version three without getting getting to
version 1.0 and I thought that was a
great point cuz he's right like you
don't you don't get VR any people's
hands unless you try it right and and
they seem very committed to it and I was
actually happy to hear even though I
don't I don't like you are I'm a maybe
next generation maybe invest in it but
I'm glad to hear that they're still
dedicating
to it yes if they have an abandoned it
because that's that's a you got it
that's a huge investment
you
and one that says the back with matter
baby I got you Brian yeah that kind of
like you know like I don't know about
him like I hope someone's scripting
stuff for him because he seems to well
they put him in a position now where
he's about the business moving for like
he he really should have making any
color it's all that's gonna be the show
on basically so yes not to be doing you
know any of the any of the press
releases interviews a lot not him but
the cross-play thing was interesting you
know I think like King said there there
in the they're the driver's seat they
really don't have to do anything but I
do think they should because I think
Microsoft has put himself in a really
interesting position coming into to next
console generation and we get you know
we had uh we had David Jaffe on a couple
weeks ago and that was great interview
yeah you know David the Saudi guy he's
he's that he made all his games I'm you
know work partnering with Sony he said
he thinks Microsoft and he said this
before we went on live because III think
Microsoft with cross play with game pass
he current you know halo gears those you
know the big franchises they have plus
you know the acquisitions of his new
studios he's like you know their
position they could take Sony's lunch
next generation yeah I heard what he
said that was a problem statement okay
let's get and then all right my opinion
on it was smoking mirrors and crap I'm
gonna keep it 100 which you don't have
to do a damn thing y'all can sit here
beg and plead and yell and scream they
don't have to do anything they won't do
anything they're not gonna get anybody a
leg up until they have to do it
Microsoft is doing all this stuff
because they are losing so don't get it
twisted like oh they're doing it over
here and therefore the people run when
they win and they not for the people not
for the people right now they are
winning
you are still following them so let's
keep it a buck when you don't have to do
something you won't do it until the
moment that they force you to move your
hands oh now they're gonna have to be in
a position of looking at Microsoft from
behind and then they're gonna have to
try to catch up and we've a bit they've
been doing this this little dance
there's a little one-two step
long time and they're like I believe
sovereign is telling the truth again
with a sauce to Dharma so sorry Thomas
they talk in the background you're gonna
leave this generation because we're
gonna bumble it to the death and your
turn now and oh y'all about to do I see
your stocks is low
alright so we gonna come out there see
some totally idiotic like hey we gonna
put this in the box charge you more give
you less power like who the hell like if
you really had to write this down like
hi this is a formula to lose right so it
slowly set all the right stuff they
actually went to the background and said
okay we're gonna do this all that stuff
was char Laden they're switching titles
they're letting you know I'm in the
front I'm doing this is going this way
oh you want to talk about cross
progression and you will sit there wait
until they're forced through the hand
listen let's not forget for tonight
forced them to yeah what night is a
juggernaut of movement within itself
that forced them to get down or lay down
now they can even say they're gonna say
okay well if you're not gonna do that
what we're gonna do is just give all his
stuff to Microsoft and Nintendo and
everybody else who wants to play fair oh
so when you have to force the big dude
to move forward
then he's gonna move forward right now
Sony's in control y'all might not like
it that's how it goes alright and when
you the boss nobody tells the boss what
to do let me jump in and get out of here
listen all great I'm excited to care for
coming through he had to bounce out but
to me I'm what you saw Robbie I got two
things out of any of you I mean think
his games of his service answer is
actually actually respected it in the
sense that he just say no to it and he
was willing was willing to like even
partner with other people as far as that
but he still gave me that vibe that
single player is to Elaine and that's
what they gonna do you know saying so I
did like that and you know they all must
be really the king of the single-player
narrative experience you know I mean you
so I rocked with him on that as far as
staying in his Lane
he also had his chest out about Sony
paying leaders and now follow us but I
have to give him in the VR space that is
true Astro bar is killing it
they've definitely pushed and they
haven't Sony notoriously had a history
of kana sometimes running away from
peripherals and with VR they are
invested so the funny part of hito is
like the cloud stuff you know things I
don't a fair play always kill Xbox and
stuff fans were saying that you know but
he kind of said like look you know
they're kind of gonna do the same thing
Microsoft is doing his sense of you know
they're not caring about what console
are playing on but he literally was
reiterating with Phil Spencer said that
you know they're going to have you on
any device you know I'm saying not a
cross play you know let's just call it
what it is you know it's a kind of guy I
don't say he got caught out there but
it's whether there's the disc
communication is miscommunication
between the top level and the actual
devs but what he's saying ain't matching
up to what the devil said you know buddy
so they got to get that string because
cross play is definitely something that
the devs want a lot of you know at this
point as far as gaming as far as
thriving communities and more
importantly like like bloody said cross
progression so that's to me even more
important I will cross brought the the
VR because that that's the one thing
that's that I said this generation they
proved me wrong on baby always drop
peripherals nowhere to go I have been in
Sony's can't with peripherals so long
and to see them always a bad I'm still
in my feelings on the ps2 yeah they got
rid of that then they did that I to 2.0
on the injury got rid of that then they
didn't I move when they did the Sony
work now for this video but I'm about to
some of you because coming and no one's
coming that's well yeah I already oh I
got that Pro you know that's all I got
man this is crazy little show we got to
finish up sorry yeah but it was late but
we had to fit isn't no do I a people
this week so with the final release of
crackdown 3 Kings hot fire and most with
mostly negative reviews of the kitchen
do you think the Xbox fan base should
demand more from Microsoft in terms of
game quality moving forward the choices
are a yes the damage control for Xbox
exclusives hurt the brand right I know
where perhaps go know Microsoft is
already addressing with new studios most
of you had no intention of buying
crackdown 3 anyway Tom about it Oh see I
don't care it's all funny games it's a
better critic rips my favorite game I
hope it goes up Lloyd bloody knuckles
absolute pleasure to have you in a
building Lord
brap absolute pleasure Lord Kratos
absolute pleasure to have you guys in
the building
Lord bloody wick and if I'm people find
you what do you have going on sir for
those who missed it yesterday I did on
my channel if they go over to
youtube.com slash bloody knuckles I did
a Valentine's Day episode for all things
anime related with some lovely ladies
from the community
I had sharise from grown woman gaming
yes I love sharise and of course I had
this sweetheart sugar which sling a
special streamer I met walls at pax
south there are they're talking about
things so make sure y'all go check that
out we did go over our favorite white
foods and house Bondo's and all that
stuff very anime related and you saw the
presentation I definitely stepped up my
game over there I'll see you brother
I'll see you know things a lot of
changing over there and of course it can
find me
Thursday's over with salty and and the
guys from TSG so whenever every Friday
they can also find me on GOG with Kay
mega and his crew what we want to be and
then of course they also want to make
sure that they're checking out the tech
games Network world.you channel because
I'll be over there with my boy JD on the
outside of the otaku fix got over to DWG
toda la la help ya grow when make game
Amy
they head off for Saturday's y'all 12
yeah yo newly check them out support
around baby in here wrapping with I ope
have to show love we got to get the loud
we got to be all I'm in here definitely
than that just everyone I love the the
love I got in the chat earlier when
everyone was here my history was was
very special in humbling and actually I
got probably one of my first fan mails
from thanks to you guys because on Xbox
I was I got a friend request and talked
to the person they added me because they
saw me on your guys's pardon and fell in
love with what I talked about so that
was very special so you guys it's it's
thanks to y'all forgive me out there but
everyone follow me on Twitter Instagram
YouTube mixer calm especially I'm always
streaming I'm doing a giveaway all my
informations bloody knuckles the O's is
zero the ease of three and it ends in a
Z oh so don't check it out guys far the
boy spending more is just now you are
for alright sure there we go Yeah right
there everyone check it out that's
what's up my shot the bloody because
again it's good to support the
up-and-coming content creators he's got
his own lane he's doing this day the
kids out here working hard and we
definitely wanna support that because
like I said people gave us an
opportunity love back it dependable man
if you do a good content you will
eventually be in the realm and salute
brother I'm glad that up people are
finally getting a chance to see what you
do so that's dope
rap from the basement radio Orkut one of
my favorite podcast reppin these are
ninjas in the building for real you
don't find people find what you got
going on run all right yeah you can find
us on YouTube at the basement radio
arcade podcast 9:00 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time you know so follow me on
the Twitter's at rap underscore podcast
and I just want to say gentlemen thank
you it's always an honor and pleasure to
be on the show look what you guys are
doing keep up the great work thank you
so much man shoutout to the team
got a shot I'll be money Eric Jackson I
like when you say it with the good
they're coming
I call them like the park has brothers
gaming for take it slow mole a dynamic
they have and they just the energy they
bring to the show you guys are really
killing some great interviews please
check out the interviews they've been
doing man really good show and what time
again so we got it for the people so
they know for breath
yep Wednesday's 9 p.m. yes entertainment
is 9 p.m. please check them out man fire
fire podcast doesn't get enough credit
man yeah and we actually giving away a
copy of anthem I should I should mention
all thanks for coming through but I love
your insight on the crackdown and so
many stuff always a pleasure thank you
my pleasure discussions with my brother
so that's what's up there so well yeah
but Lord addict had to run his wealth
chart there me to work but uh Lord solve
what can find people find you what you
got going on sir poor is now big set out
to bloody knocks well wrap into cradles
for coming through there in this trailer
it's no episode we had today
yeah and appreciate everybody sticking
around man we had a high count entire
show sticking around so thank you so
much for that support we really
appreciate it I'm I'm guessin catch me
Twitter north/south IOP PSN xbox live at
being sovereign caught you Annette de la
Pole video recently out yeah right off a
goddamn hero unlock yeah I did one for
Black History Month Jack's he went in on
on the Jack scarily check out all of the
LA post videos period but hero unlocked
is really really cool because those in
depth with the history of all of this
games if Eric there's really really well
done actually production values go check
out walk I'm here to check yeah
- Bo - yeah yo his content is so good yo
please if you ever checked our brother
out he's part of this dream team lord
dalabo AKA potentially perfect search
that in youtube potentially perfect the
brothers out here great content man he's
been doing it for a while it's finally
getting some recognition so the lures
are definitely going to support him he's
supposed to be in here with us aw we're
supposed to have I was gonna do like a
wrestling move where you hit the music
Pearl Harbor Lord King
aka Lord dialog let me tell you um I
love the fact that cradles came on my
brother a lot of times people like to
say stupid things about the man but the
man thinks about what he's about to say
and he doesn't regurgitate other crap
from other people he has his own lane
and he speaks the truth 90% of the time
I'm down with everything that he says
shout out to my man braaap braap got it
we got to get to Apex now I think we
moved on a page yes
and shout out the bloody see you in Cali
- the last topic I know you're probably
looking at black Disney base area um get
to black does it bear this 4k 30 frames
per second no the Beautiful Oh beautiful
I have to give you a house I can't pick
this time then I downloaded debate our
city Oh bro and what you can go through
like I said they were born and stuff but
I want to give that a try as out in beta
it's free go check that out
oh there's on Xbox Dashboard oh listen
yeah see the stuff videos and stuff is
coming this week we have a hundred
episode coming next week nice happening
is
that's going on this is a place that you
want to be yeah trust me when I tell you
you do not want to miss the hundred
episode and then in DM me to find out
about that five hundred dollar champagne
the King on am a king did you ever do
your spicy noodle challenge last year Oh
nobody nobody told you hit me up we
gonna do it refuses never free you'll
say that you don't ever say you doing
anything for free absolutely
yo Shelby hit that like that subscribe
notification gang please you don't
saying please do that and also real
quick on what you got like if you guys
like the concert please retweet man it
really helps us if you if anything about
the show you enjoyed please retweet say
spread the word man we try to do
positive content and like called King
said episode 100 y'all better be in a
building to drop we gonna have some fun
thank you guys for the support make sure
you support the stream team as well you
know I'm sayin lost Naldo l-boogie that
was in a chat old-school style MJ is a
boss in Lord the liable himself
all screaming each and every week on
twitch.tv slash iron law podcast calm
North Kaibab so he's gonna have on the
order up later on today Spotify iTunes
SoundCloud Google Play all that good
stuff links will be in description as
will get everybody's link in there but
get bloody knuckles smash podcast otaku
fix on tick please catch that as well
you and I'm saying and then we're also
gonna have brat podcasters link as well
as cradles I don't know if he's doing a
scum caster but I'll get that
information man because like y'all still
alive yeah though it's crazy and of
course you already know the last word
with myself and he boxes talking all
that muda to talk we
very fiery in there please catch that
one who's a destiny versa oh yeah yeah
King with the best to be better I'm with
you boy I'm with autism we will fight it
was literally a Division two versus
anthem podcast very fun trials trials
without all that good stuff but yeah man
thanks everyone for the support
enjoy your Sunday if anybody got
anything else all right we go G well we
know we not go Gian Louis Vuitton out of
here that's right as you gotta do but
everybody enjoy your Sunday I got so
much peace thank you
listen this for hours